[Music]
four
sometimes when i got in public people
will sing it to me and i'm like
that song is so fucking annoying it's a
crazy person
i love it well it's based on um the
robot whitney and a robot a real
uh song from a show in that i loved and
but we're gonna get we'll get a new one
soon
we want to do a whole thing where people
submit new opening jingle songs and some
people have but i just haven't
kept track of any but we will soon maybe
have an email set up i don't know yeah
we gotta
we gotta have those we're gonna start to
we're gonna start to have emails and
po boxes we're getting a pc
so people can send items letters
anthrax death threats okay guys you're
really with the negativity
we're gonna have to draw straws on who
opens the mail i'll open them all
you have a lot to live for actually
grace you're more necessary than
either of us we'll do it if we die we'll
make it uh uh
so we're getting a p.o box we're going
to get of the photo
photoshop we're getting photoshop we're
going to begin
we're going to get uh we're going to get
word documents mine sweepers
dude we are going to get adobe acro
we're getting a fax machine
we are getting all we're a real pi it's
been a year
we're just recreating a set from nine to
five no
now that now that it is it is maybe
clear that the stand-up business is
dying i'm ready to really commit to this
watch really gets to business
i'm really into faxes emails we've got
wi-fi
look at us but we did we got new
lighting we got lighting rigged on the
ceiling you can't see it
you can't see it but you don't always
hear also you can't see my crow's feet
so the po box is gonna be really fun
because we can write letters back
oh no that's
i mean the boyfriend what is wrong with
you can someone put on a dating app it's
20 21.
are you on a dating app emily i'm sure
we're inquiring mine's one another
and go hey who wants to date me
wait emily it's actually very annoying
to me because emily and i are usually
single at the same time and i'm sorry
i hate that you are i hate when i have a
new daddy i hate it too
but the guy the guy that i'm dating is
actually pretty in love with emily so
i don't know how this is gonna go emily
you know what he said
you people fall in love with you like
not the people in the comments
not our fans not your fans
um yeah guys be nice to emily she hasn't
you know um
you know she's like me and ben she
hasn't been like put through the ringer
of
of uh uh becoming calloused in the
comedy people loved her growing up
stand up business for for so long so be
gentle with her she's not as much of a
masochist
someone wrote she's too needy it's like
well duh ma'am
yeah no shit as you're on the podcast
like please find me a boyfriend
but also like no good comedian is not
needy if we weren't needy we wouldn't be
doing this for a living right yeah
we need approval from strangers this is
we all do emily's just a little uh
more obvious about it she just hasn't
figured out how to hide it yet
she just can't really play it cool you
only have the sticker on her car honk if
you love me
so emily doesn't have a car but um
talking about to have a needy
she doesn't need a boyfriend she needs
uh literally just someone who has a car
a chauffeur she'll take anyone at this
point yeah she needs she needs an uber
frankly um so uh tour
dates we are coming back the pandemic
can
kiss my tush
we've figured out a way to do this
safely uh places are starting to open up
we are triumphing
over uh tragedy april 15th to 17th
we're in spokane we're adding shows how
many we're adding like five shows i
think
do you know grace i don't think it's
five we're adding shows and grace
obviously doesn't believe in me that i
can add five shows but whatever we'll do
it's like it's a half a show yeah i
won't do late shows true
that is true i will not i will not uh uh
because we'd like to go out on the town
mommy's getting older mommy mommy
mommy's auntie whitney's got to be home
by like 9 15 now so we're we're starting
the show
yeah we're doing we're doing brunch
shows from some bingos yeah
the show sounds fun dude there i used to
go on the road dude i would go on the
road
yeah we're doing all these shows and
then i get there and you've been on it
red eye
you haven't slept all day you've been
doing radio since five in the morning
with like
chuckle bucket in the morning oh and the
later it gets and mike
in the fm and chuckle buckets and then
it's like you
get there and you realize the friday
show starts at 10
30 which means 11 and then the opener
goes
and you're going on it like truly which
means the people have been drinking
since seven
and they've been working all day and
they didn't get tickets for the first
show so they fucking had to go to the
second show
they had some to say and they're away
they got feedback excited they are
thrilled and they want two participants
and they did not win employee of the
month this year
and they are pissed about it and so
i i am gonna draw some boundaries around
late shows
uh uh but we're adding a bunch of shows
in spokane
april 22nd and 24th we're going to san
antonio
yeehaw wait it's called the lol comedy
club
lol wait i didn't i didn't know that
i've never what i didn't know that
that's what it's called
i didn't know i've never been there
before so this shit don't blame your
fans for the names of
i'm not i'm just saying this is the
first i've heard of the name of the club
benton and i are
one that's the one lol comedy club bench
and i are coming to that one
well but r-o-f
will be vaccinated because benton just
signed up uh to get the vaccine
what number in line one million eight
hundred seventy four thousand three
hundred and forty seven person in my
area on the list so guys here's hoping
that is so funny to me benton is one in
two
million in two hundred thousand um
houston
improv may 13th to 15th brea improv
which is basically southern california
day after my birthday
may 7th to an eighth so we'll have a
benton birthday show
oh benton birthday breast show are you
gonna be 30 why would you say that
i'm sorry okay well actually that's rude
to the two of us i'm just kidding i
don't care about age look at me i'm 12.
you can't uh okay phoenix
arizona you're going to get more of us
than you ever would have wanted
we're coming may 29th to 30th and
june 2nd and 3rd to cb live
in phoenix you're just going to keep her
in arizona that whole week like a week
and a half
let's just keep her there right now no
it is because look june 4th or 6th
stand up live tempe i'm going to be
you're gone from the 29th to the sixth
yes
happy birthday emily you'll be there
tonight
you'll be there too no i'm not busy
you'll be in there you'll be in phoenix
so we get days off while we're there
okay everyone just calm down no i mean
like to do stuff in the city
yeah wow phoenix has a great urban
outfitters
what and a great idea so does the
internet think of something else
what does that even mean we are we never
have free days in cities we can go
great canyon we can go to i want to go
to bryce canyon can we jump in it no no
i want to go to oh this is in santa fe
go to that horse there i want to see if
i can make that horse flip its ankle
back at miraval
uh that guy uh i just want to eat
somewhere but you know that you can at
maraval this is the horse therapy
place at marvel you know you can do that
with me anytime and that's what i
literally do every day all i want
is a horse to like me okay and that's
the best way the more you're eating the
more you
need a horse and they can't do it the
more you i am needy
the more you need the more you need a
horse to like you the less
the more repellent it is please tell us
things to do in phoenix yes well i
were there for two weeks the guy that
i'm dating is from phoenix so i'm
meeting his family
and then uh uh we're coming to one of my
favorite
clubs in the world on the east coast
which i love this
l this the name is every time i say it i
i
it's a bittersweet it's called magooby's
joke house
in balt baltimore bulmer as i'm from dc
baltimore's a big deal mcgooby's joke
house
will work on the name uh i kind of love
it i love the name i love the name but
the venue is unbelievable i uh for my
last special i
ran it the night before uh because i if
i'm shooting in dc
my special i'll run it mcgoobies the
night before it's got this beautiful
stage
it's like stadium seating it's an
awesome awesome venue
june 10th and 12th uh through 12th i'm
sorry you know what we're going to do
then
go to dc i'm going to emily's from
i'm going to bring my family to
mcgoobies and whitney
seven eight you're meeting double family
eight years in the making
whitney's gonna meet my family i have so
many words you have so much feedback
i have a lot to talk about
i mostly want to talk to your mother
about not allowing you to give yourself
a wedgie for a man on the internet for 7
because i think she's just like dropping
the ball as a parent but we'll talk
about that in person and she will get it
i thought before we get to donnell
rawlings who is here
this is really just a family tour you're
just going state to state meeting
families
yes yeah i'm actually in the market for
a new family myself uh
i have family in uh dallas and in
sherman texas i'm gonna go visit
my family members that's great
reconnecting so
clubhouse clubhouse i just wanted us to
see if this is something we want to do
with the podcast
uh because clubhouse is this app that's
like um
it's like a live chat room where you can
uh
uh start rooms and talk to people this
could be a way that we can start talking
to fans like more regularly
if you guys sign up for clubhouse and we
start rooms uh
so we wanna kind of experiment with it
now i'm sure this is gonna be a complete
disaster
because i'm just starting a room out of
nowhere so normally you would like
schedule rooms and then
but i'm just going to start it right now
and just see if anybody this is like if
we all had walkie-talkies and you were
like what are y'all doing
yeah to literally so anyone that follows
me on clubhouse now is going to get a
notification that i'm signing on right
now live
on the podcast they hear you or see you
so it says start a room so i'm just
going to start a room
okay can i see so i can um
the hair monitor yeah um start a room
start a room
open to everyone great this is going to
be chaos i mean it's
it is like 12 30 people are probably at
work uh so it's probably at night it's
even more crazy
okay so here it is you guys can see it
i'm trying to make it so it's not there
okay
here goes nothing wait i can add you as
a moderator benton no i'm sad you're not
meeting my family
okay i'm gonna work i've been trying to
meet your family for so
long longer than you're trying to be my
family no because your family uh scarce
that's impossible
and benton's mom and i are the same
person so i'm just want to meet my twin
at some point
um okay so here we go let's go the room
is starting here we go let's
go do you see that so so i pop up
and then no one's in the room yet so
wait explain this to me as if i were a
90 year old grandmother
so it's an empty room like a chat room
okay you join it and instead of typing
you talk yeah so some people just hear a
voice
when it's their turn to talk how do you
know what's their turn to talk
that pops up but emily let's just do it
and it'll become so obvious like that's
the thing it's impossible someone's
there
one person's two people have joined
three people have joined high three
people
okay so can you guys hear yes they can
all hear me
okay um okay so we have three four
so people are joining for everyone who's
listening
uh i am live on the podcast now and
we wanted to see about doing a clubhouse
during the podcast
and if you guys raise your hand and ask
questions we'll answer them
oh while you do that i'll start an
instagram live room no no
no so if someone raises their hand okay
tommy just raised
look tommy just raised his hand hey
tommy
wait invite to speak
hi tommy tommy
hey how's it going whitney it's going
you're live on our podcast tommy where
are you
uh los angeles oh where outside my house
in the bushes i actually live in a tent
you live in a tent yeah most people in
l.a do it like this one
ac it's working out pretty good how why
are you available right now at 12 30 on
a weekday
well because i'm homeless i get to do
whatever i want you're homeless with an
iphone and clubhouse
yeah um so late whitney haven't you
seen the millionaires that we're
homeless people billionaires yes so
um so we're just trying this out um
how do we go to someone else not that
you're not a delight
uh uh no we're i'm just sorry
is there another person that wants to
raise their hand i don't know how to do
this sorry
in a way that's fair you need to
probably you need to get a mod
it doesn't seem like you're advanced at
clubhouse yet okay oh wait
someone just got asked to be invited so
you guys have to raise your hand oh
that's what you do you go to people that
raises their hands got it okay and then
oh andrew schultz is trying to join oh
oh andrew's here asshole army we're
doing clubhouse live on the
oh podcast it's not going great
andrew hi whitney
hi andrew shulson
the king tell tell me how to use this
what
this is what you do you're going to go
to that uh button at the bottom that
says
leave quietly
and then we all save our dignity how
about that
is that good and then i oh so that i can
go make a tick tock video
is that what you're saying so that i can
go do the tick tock
yes let's do some tick tock so what do i
so i go down to the bottom and i fax
uh a leave quietly yes we go down to the
bottom and then we
fax the leaf wildlife it is just perfect
i love you what are you doing i'm in my
hotel room in columbus ohio oh
i see you know i got absolutely nothing
to do this just became a fun to have
it's pretty bad this is pretty and it's
also funny because we get along
so well and we have such good chemistry
but this is incredibly awkward
can other people in the room hear you
guys
okay leave quietly then leave quietly
stop telling me you have to go we get it
we got it bye-bye
um so these are all the people that know
there are tons of people in the room
right now look at all these and they can
all hear they can all hear what we're
saying they can hear you talking andrew
yes
but they you can't hear that are they
talking to each other no could you
imagine
yeah well no no they're all it's
basically to me it's like it's like um
going to a like a festival or a
convention where there's conversations
happening and
you go from room to room to different
like ted talks and different
conversations
and i can invite other people to host it
with people can all these people raise
their hand to ask questions
so um jessica casler i'm going to say
jessica this is the weirdest thing i've
ever done in my life yeah no shit
meet you are a weirdo all of a sudden i
just hear whitney cummings like speaking
on my phone i don't even know what
clubhouse is but
um so wait you're doing the podcast
right now we're recording the podcast
right now seeing if this would be a cool
thing to do on the podcast to like talk
to fans live
so far it's not so far it's not going
great can you change that
do you why haven't you monetized it yet
oh shit he's back oh i forgot
he's still here um what's your name
tommy's still here oh
so see there's more than one person in
the in there can you fix it now before
we keep going
fix what there's no way to do this he
wants to silence all these people i'm
adding them and they can all kind of
chat with us look valerie joyner i'm i'm
adding you hi valerie so then valerie's
in here too
val
val hello hey girl where are you val
uh i'm in l.a i'm in rancho palace
verdes i don't expect you to um
let me just speak but hey how's it going
i'm good what did you how can we do this
in a way that is entertaining to fans is
should we do this yeah you absolutely
should do this i'm pretty um
fairly new to clubhouse too but from
what i understand i feel like this is
gonna
maybe be the new networking for
introverts or
it's like going to a bar yeah um but
then you can
shop the other bars and see who's in
them while you're at the bar ooh
i love that just change you love bars
it's fun so
yeah and then it's great for networking
for professionals and
cool shit like this like i'm talking to
you yeah you're you're talking to me
that's wild
juanita i'm bringing you in hayden i'm
bringing you in
so look we can just talk to all of our
fans we can get ashley elizabeth there
you are
i mean i'm adding way too many people i
feel like this is not how people
normally do it but i feel like next time
we come in with like a game plan and
we're talking about a specific topic
we can go in and we can really like
engage with people yeah this is cool
who else is here leah lee i love you i
want to just um give you some like
clubhouse basics
i thought you were to say i want to give
you some constructive feedback i was
like whoa i was like
hang up hang out doing real south real
fast yes clubhouse basics
so um it's i just joined the room but it
sounds like you may be recording in
which case you just have to like
make a quick announcement frequently to
people that you are recording
[Music]
recording on the podcast yes yes yes so
as to be on like the up and up with
clubhouse and not get like kicked off
before this
even starts yeah oh dude i would like
dude i would love nothing more than to
be kicked off because i put it as like a
title as the title of the room whenever
you make it oh
put it like a reminder at first when
people join if they want to speak they
already know
so i have to know i have to let everyone
know uh good for you podcast
being recorded live or something so
everyone knows
i think that would be a good idea that
feels fair well you did say that but
it's good to type it
got it that they have written i think
right now
the room doesn't have a name it just
shows you and your room so
uh you can make a room with a title and
you can schedule it
uh let's say if you want to do this i
don't know
every other podcast you do or whatever
you can schedule it and then it shows up
on
people's calendar and then uh just make
the title
you know that you're recording it for
your podcast love okay so that people
know and then also make it like a
regular what's the best time to do it do
you think what's the what's the best
time to be on clubhouse
right now is it
i think for clubhouse it's just like uh
you get the notification when people you
follow uh like make a room i
people are on clubhouse like just
whenever i haven't figured out like a
specific time
when people are on it it's just all the
time
it seems to be like evenings when um
people on the west coast are out of work
and people on the east coast are also
no longer working and like people with
kids that those sort of
obligations um are all finished with
everything so people are up like all
night on this app
not yes i have been on it a lot i just
haven't we haven't really done it with
the podcast yet so i've been
on it a bunch and um uh but now i want
to see if you guys want let's go around
real quick round robin if you guys want
to ask questions
just a reminder it's not titled here but
this is being recorded for the podcast
um but i'm a boomer so it's not in the
thing
matt i'm adding uh aydah ashley
hi hi where are you um i'm in
indiana nice
yeah so i think anytime is a good time
because people stop
sleeping it sounds like whenever they
use this app so sure it's
so addictive and then also if you
want to title it anything with
manifesting that seems to be very
popular
that's so funny my question is
can you tell us about anything you've
ever manifested
oh shit i've where's my where's can you
go grab my vision board
do you know where it is i just we're
moving and i found my vision board
and i've pretty much gotten everything
on it
i pre and by the way one time i uh
was sort of obsessed with this hollywood
actor slash director and i had a picture
of him on my wall and i ended up dating
him eight years later
i had a picture of him on my wall that i
like pulled out of a gq magazine
why did you do you know who he was like
i didn't really know who he was
but i loved the r i actually pulled it
because i it was like art inspo
because it was a bunch of black and
white photos that were in a way that i
wanted
to like use as like it was before
pinterest yeah and i had a bunch of
stuff on a cork board and he was on it
because of that and then we ended up so
i kind of like
accidentally maybe i have to make one i
learned that's why i was looking at you
i liked it because you want a boyfriend
that's how you get one okay we found my
vision board you're about to get way
more than you guys do this is so cool
okay this is just this was my feet here
i'll hold it hold that no no i'll just
put it over here oh
this is my vision oops oh is that
catherine keener you guys can't see it
okay
it it's got let's see uh you guys will
see this when you watch the episode that
comes out uh
with this what's on it ellen's on it
i've been on
ellen crazy whitney i know i feel like i
made this problem
huh you've hosted it i have you've done
all of this yeah this is matt this is
magical isn't that wild
all you have to do is win your grammy no
i have not alexander payne the directors
on here i've not worked with him
tina fey's on here i have i've met her
but i haven't worked with her you will
it's
don't say you have it you still will yes
and then
yes yeah there's still some you guys are
inspiring me and then uh
todd phillips is on here who's a
director i haven't worked with judd
apatow's on here
i did his book like he did a book about
comedy and i've done shows with him
uh jim carrey i've met not worked with
what's this what's this thing what's
this a talk show
oh yeah okay i had that what's this
right here that's inside the actor's
studio
oh yeah no that's not gonna happen isn't
james slipped and canceled or dead oh
yeah well
he's the ultimate canceled which is yeah
dead and i did larry david is on here i
did audition for curb like
six years ago and totally bombed it that
counts that's so nuts and that's funny
and then katherine keener
i love it it's my dream to work with her
and i'm still holding out
so yes i think vision boards i'm a
vision board bitch dude
i think they work vision board party i
would love to see
them on curb too i would love to too to
tell that to larry david
i i think i should i shit the bed in my
audition majorly
no worries there's always a second come
around i love you you guys this is very
inspiring
okay who is next hold on uh uh nathan
steph steph do you have a question steph
or a comment or a
criticism i no criticism just a question
if you could have dinner with three
people
dead or alive who would those three
people be such a great question
um dead or alive um
this uh mae west because i would want to
know
i'm obsessed with mae west who was kind
of the first
female comedian in some ways but there's
rumors that she wasn't
female that she wasn't white that she
had to you know but she also took
control of her own
destiny she was like writing her own
movies she was you know writing her own
uh roles and stuff um she really played
with masculine and feminine in a way
that was like
you know very subversive at the time so
i would i have some questions for mae
west
um oh man this is hard
you guys help me who um with ours with
uh
yeah we'll go around emily and uh uh
benjamin will also go i mean
um lauren hill
oh that's a good yeah good guess um
what are yours while i'm thinking of my
last one
see it's a hard question it is a hard
question i didn't think it through
what if i cheated and said the three of
you no
well that is you're liv we can just
start snacking right now and we're sort
of it's happening
i'll die for you we're eating a meal
together this is lovely
she's so dead or alive so you're allowed
to live oh oh okay then
what are yours um joan rivers yeah nice
um yes oh yeah elizabeth bathory
who's that she's a lady who used to um
kidnap people and bathe in their blood
and they locked her in her own tower
yeah i love it okay and i want to know
why
okay emily so that'll be why okay and
then she'd say because i'm nuts and the
dinner will be over
they thought she was a wage but they
couldn't kill her because she was royal
so they had just let her keep doing it
live in a little house
oh emily oh my god i this is a hard
question because it's like who would i
really want who do i think sounds cool
we're probably overthinking it you're
asking a bunch of like just answer the
question like i did
insecure comedians that those are good i
don't i honestly don't know i
you know what i'm going to say something
that's not particularly funny but i
would i'll pick emily's
okay bill nye the science guy john
mullaney
oh lovely and um ronald mcdonald and
caroline callaway her hero
where are you you're new york healthcare
tag yeah new york city
oh love it make it a good question okay
a good ques
benton says make thank you thank you the
blue hair has got to go soon
uh but uh so enjoy it while you can all
right well
we'll do i also watched the female brain
recently i uh thoroughly enjoyed it with
friends it was awesome
thank you thank you for agreeing emily
and i decided that
we're going to do a podcast episode with
some of the cast members of the female
brain to explain everyone what a
nightmare it was to make
um and yeah we would love to ruin the
movie you just said you like yeah
no that's the goal of hollywood you like
the movie watch
yeah no that's a great no i actually
love getting those perspectives i'll
listen to that podcast as soon as it
comes out
oh just you like you know it looks so
perfect as a final result but like what
is all the trauma and craziness that
went into it from everyone involved it
does look perfect
i think it's really good to know the
nightmare it's like so you want to make
a movie
i'm going to tell you all the nightmares
if anyone wants to make an independent
movie please watch a documentary called
lost in la mancha about terry gilliam
um making um uh uh don quixote
and that's like a little inside of the
nightmare um and
uh amy what's your question also that
cast was incredible so
thank you agree i feel like this was an
interesting experiment
next time we'll be a little more
polished about it uh and then we'll have
like a theme which is like
ask us questions or like you know would
you rather yeah would you rather truth
or dare like something that'll be like a
little more like organized
maybe we'll do like game nights maybe
yeah like we'll like do some cool shit
on here but so any ideas you guys
you guys have sent them to me because
clearly we don't have any because this
is what we think a good version of it is
fun they can text oh shit tommy's back
what
on a serious note whitney you could
create a club that way you can actually
schedule your events
it's really easy to do so just throwing
that out there oh
yeah tommy how do you know all this
tommy tommy do you wanna you own
that same you start a clubhouse
then we could click on the green house
and follow you so we know when things
are coming
so we all have what if we built a
treehouse instead yes yes
i love this this is the modern day
treehouse but we follow you
um all right i'm gonna learn clubhouse
so i can do this with you guys
thank you for uh helping me um you guys
are awesome
yeah thanks guys you're welcome welcome
why haven't you given yourselves this
clubhouse why haven't i given my
assistance clubhouse
uh what does that mean i invited uh did
i invite you grace to clubhouse
yeah i invited grace to clubhouse my
sister she only has one assistant i
think she ignored
it you're on it so grace is on it
uh emily's not my assistant but she's on
it benton's not my assistant but he's on
it too so benton
emily you're not really on it um but
yeah so we're all going to get on there
you guys will get to know everyone i
just want to start
uh connecting with you guys more um and
you know what this made me want to do
what
open a speakeasy open a speakeasy that's
kind of what it's like
and look how nice everybody was people
like it gets toxic nope not not our
friends
not our friends not our club not our
club so you guys if you spoke you'll see
yourself next week
or hear yourself um on the podcast uh
please don't sue me and until then write
us a poem never awesome
love you guys okay i don't know how to
get out do i just don't write out
my elephants perfect i love you
brandon ooh brandon shirtless brand
lovely brandon
bye love you guys okay so am i still on
i can't i don't know if i can
quietly leave quietly okay i tried um so
we'll make that a thing it sounds so fun
right it's fun it's like people are nice
we'll start getting feedback live
feedback
i like questions i love questions too
yeah
i don't like to answer but i love when
you guys i love you me too but it'll be
good for but it's also
um and they can help us guide what we
talk about what guess we said what
guests do you want to see on the show so
we'll start getting more feedback from
you guys
um how much skin do you want to see on
the show how much how much skin do you
want to see
how much cleavage do you want to see we
come in math yeah
is this better um okay we got to go
donnell rawlings is here
it's funny it's emotional he
uh lubes me up with his new body butter
it's called
i'm rich raw edge body butter
um i love you guys enjoyed donnell
rawlings uh
uh like comment subscribe merch don't
forget to buy merch we love you
what do you need we got you an uh uh
hold on are we rolling pat have a
feeling
we got you an um uh soy milk latte your
favorite
uh my question is how do you know what
my favorite coffee is
i don't i just you like like like the
internet like big brother like you say
like i must have said coffee on my phone
one day and you got some type of link
it lets you know just coffee out like no
i know you're like white girl so i
figured wait a minute
first off before we even do that there's
a room on the streets that that's what i
like
okay i like everybody just so happened i
spent a lot of times with creeks rivers
and beaches and for some reason the
african-american community does not
support those outdoor activities
so i mean for the peace to sisters and
black lives always
matter understand this um
if you spend more time on the beach if
you spend more time kayaking canoeing
if you spend more time having your own
herb garden and stuff like that
then there's a chance that you can get
with the uh ashley elba that's my new
name
i'm the ghetto version of egypt israel's
elf in my mind
i'm the hood version i'm saying if he
just elvis smoked blunts
he would be me um yeah no exactly like
exactly like sometimes i look at you and
i'm like is that
no that's not now like i could i'm
always confused
where's um this little what is your dog
named maggie what are you doing hi baby
how are you thanks for doing this let's
give them something
to talk about let's go
breathing on each other this is called
negative
this is feet called negative pcr this is
where the world needs to get back to by
the way not
ashy at all not
at all not in the slightest
what happens sometimes i'm pretty sure
look is
i'm not a great ad for your new lotion
it's a funny thing that you would say
that because i have a gift for you yes
give it to me i'm a rich ultra body
lotion
more lotion for you and it's not just a
gimmick it is filled with all type of
things that white women like it's shea
butter
yup it's uh montgomery oil you're
probably not familiar with that whenever
i say that people say i don't think
you're pronouncing it right
but it's mogungo oil it's somewhere in
africa
oil montgomery montgomery like more of a
coming to america voice can we work on
this
i uh go deeper i'm so close to getting
cancelled i feel like i shouldn't push
it
you can cancel no but i just want to i
don't want to appropriate
i'm just saying we're going to talk
about that because i know that was just
you're just saying it because getting
canceled
i think the more you say i'm going to
get cancelled maybe the less you will
try to get ahead of it
here's people here's people
that get canceled with me okay who it's
people
that feel like they need something it's
people that are desperate yeah
it's not people that are independent
it's not people that build their own
brand
that's true it's not people that have
got people to fall in love with them for
years and years
it's usually the weak weak-minded people
that think they're going to need
something oh my god
if i lose this i lose that but look what
you've done for yourself in regards to
when this person like you say i'm going
to get canceled
and this is no disrespect you're not on
tv regularly
right now right you've had that
experience you were able to be very
successful at but then at the same time
okay what if these opportunities don't
present themselves to me anymore yeah
what the fuck do i do yeah
even when i remember when you first
started doing the podcast we talked to
each other in the
we talked about it and then it was like
one thing about the podcast where it
gives you a sense of independence
if you feel like i don't need these
people
to sustain a a decent lifestyle right
right that's why people always like i'll
post some shit right
and then people will be like oh nice
knowing you r.i.p
they give me twenty-one unfollow yeah i
unfollow you're canceled i'm like
you you like it's hard when you have a
fan base
and people that love you that small
percentage to try to cancel you
they can't overpower the people that
love you yeah yeah yeah actually it kind
of makes you stronger because then
you're just trying
because your people like want to get
behind you and defend you yeah and then
it's like and you're also just giving us
more press when you guys do that
we do it it's just i don't know we're
i've discovered a lot of hilarious
comedians because they like got
cancelled
i'm like it's funny yeah then people
like people
you know they make comebacks and
you know i just don't believe in the
whole cancer council culture and
especially so
because i roll with dave chappelle and
uh
i saw him pretty much say
fuck y'all i'm gonna say what i want i'm
gonna do what i want
when i want to do it and it worked
everybody don't have the balls everybody
i don't know if i said this on your
podcast but i've said it on different
platforms
when you consider especially the
business that we in we think we're great
right i think i'm great you think you're
great uh
dude i'm not known for my astronomical
self-esteem but
i think i'm good at the things that i've
worked hard so okay with that said
when you hear somebody say something uh
give
somebody else their roses not that your
envious are jealous jealous
you ask yourself i'm great but what
makes
this motherfucker great yeah yeah and i
was that was a question i asked myself
with my relationship with dave right and
i was and i said that
the thing that makes them great is that
you have people that are funny but you
don't have
a lot too many people that are funny
that have what i call a muhammad ali
moment
and a muhammad ali moment is when you
have to stand for something
when it's you you you got to consider
your morals your values and what's true
to you
and you make decisions don't don't
necessarily put in a situation for
financial gain
right you know what i'm saying muhammad
ali said he wasn't going to fight in
vietnam and shit when he was at the
prime of his career
costing millions of millions of dollars
he didn't say oh fuck that
uh maybe i'll go in and then i won't be
in war
they'll protect me or whatever but he
stood for something it's about integrity
what the point where you're you
you decide integrity is more important
than cash yeah and everybody can do that
mm-hmm you know what i'm saying i mean
like i i value integrity but
same time i like to make money yeah yeah
there's no integrity lost in cash in the
checks yeah
we uh can we just get him to apologize
you know what i mean like can we just
say you know we had a bad day when you
you called me nigger
he woke up on the wrong side of the bed
honestly muscle memory i mean hold
happens die hard
you know that's why you know when i hear
about cancer culture or something like
that
i don't really subscribe to that and
that's one of the reasons i'm excited
about the podcast i started in some
other things because
i think cancer culture helped us all
start podcasts in a way so i'm a little
bit grateful because i was just like oh
my god like we have no control over some
corporation
is going to fire us if we say jesus
christ or so or you know what i found
out
during the the pandemic and didn't uh
get into the park as well
white people have been keeping podcasts
a secret
to black people okay donald said white
people have been keeping
keeping uh you know what but here's what
i'll say
no they have it those ones just aren't
popular
they've been the popular ones aren't a
secret they kept it away from the black
community for so many years
they let us work our sets out every day
to go on the road
to make the money that they make in one
fucking podcast
well because black people like uh
usually have
a 10 there's a lot of untalented white
men that their only option is just to
sit around and talk it's true
i feel very talented neil brennan once
said neil brennan once said
the average black person is funnier than
a white
comedian no he's like an average black
person not a
yeah that's funnier than a white
comedian yeah most of the working
communities in history
it's just something i don't know if it
comes from going through so much pain
yeah adversity yeah you know like when
things hit you so much what do we do
we figure out a way to laugh so that
might contribute to
how how tough we are and how funny we
are but it's true
because i mean but not me not i did not
start a podcast to like a year ago
because you were white
but as a white woman i basically have
had it as hard as you
and um oh what the fuck is going on i
mean as
no i was just like who's gonna want to
listen to me talk for three hours like
in this business i'm like you always
have to be twice as good to get half as
much
like you know and uh and the idea of
just like guys sitting around talking i
was like but
what it like no one will ever want to
hear me talk like you know who wants to
hear a white woman just
talk for three hours i didn't know that
that was a business you know
i mean i hate to break the news for you
we start off with this conversation i
got to get my sexy voice on
right now but i would pay to hear a
white woman talk all
day preferably in a bikini probably in a
kayak
with one or then i'm the only one doing
the stroking
if you ask me who i want to have a
conversation that would be you we got
you okay
we got some snacks what yo i told you
about this shit the last time i was here
what the fuck is going on that's a
better one
i told you the last time stop trying to
save
my life this is a this is a bad i'm
gonna die that's
that's peanut butter granola that is so
bad for you that's really unhealthy
wait a minute you know how white i know
you are yeah for you to say that a
granola
is bad for you it's all sugar granola is
not that healthy
this granola let me read you the
ingredients first off there's another
cane sugar
there's another thing whitney i got his
canola oil whitney can i stop you for
yes like what you just did now
is what all white women do
at whole foods and wherever they go
white women take the longest to shop
i and i do they would be here because
we're in there looking for a husband i'm
just pushing around until somebody talks
to me hang out in the um
in the produce section over top of the
cold section you'll get a husband quick
and shit
but that's what i'm saying if you're
shopping whole foods you're rich like
why not make it with me is that how you
just i've i've i've
i've get an investigation right i've
actually followed a white woman
shopping right in whole foods and whole
foods in all the places
whole foods and stuff like that the
highest places you know the
15 a pound for kale places yeah yeah and
you just follow white women around
i don't fall around i just want to see
what their buying habits are
i just say l.a must have gotten safer
did the black boxes work you can just
follow white women around and no one
comes for you
no you just gotta have assertive
confidence when you do it you know what
i'm saying
and then when you run into them you got
like oh man i just came back from europe
you're like they like travel
talk about wine and shit talking about
trolls in a pandemic
in a panda because i just came back from
italy they're like get away from me
i know i know i know i know but what you
did was and i've seen it happen in the
shopping experience
they will get us something off the shelf
and they will read
every fucking thing they know the
calorie count
they know saturated fats from the other
fancy shit
and they'll do like this one thing like
this
and they'll put that shit back yeah yeah
they put it back it'll be all good it'll
be all good until they get that one
oh no oh sodium hydro
hydrogenated oil yeah yeah it's not this
the 20 price that makes them put it down
and then they'll be in there for 45
minutes and then when they get to the
register they still
in the express lane with
your favorite nuts raw nuts right your
favorite it will be uh avocados
i don't fuck with avocados you don't
fuck with it they go they go bad too
quick like you got if you open avocado
you it's like it's like uh the time that
starts ticking right like i already got
biological clock stress rushing me
like i don't eat avocados as soon as you
open them they're going to turn brown
and i'd get too stressed
just eat it do you know about avocado
hand how many people get avocado hand a
year
avocado hand is when you cut through an
avocado
and like you stab yourself and you cut
through your hands like can someone look
up the number of emergency room visits
that happen a year from now and then
we'll cause
all the white girls by the way you're
ready to say did someone look up who's
get cut
who's stabbing yourself the avocado hand
find out how many people
get heard of avocado wait a minute does
is that the same thing in the
in the hood as like blunt hand what's
bloodhounds
one hand is when you're trying to cut
open a philly blunt or
tobacco leaf and it's almost the same
thing as avocado
you're trying to slice the leaf and then
you cut yourself that's right
or maybe like getting your thumb shot
off
okay i went too far one too far whitney
i just want to get a thumbs up
you've been following my life right i've
been following your life there's certain
things
i'm sensitive about i'm sorry this is
whitney a place of
whitney mm-hmm all this is bullshit
got it you never really
how could you say that i'm asking you
know the mental fucking
stress the pts i just want to see it
i've been dealing with i just because i
was in a gun blaze
and i got shot defending maggie
yep who is smaller than your thumb
did your thumb protect her that's the
thing it was like a shield
it was like when the bunt when the
bullets started ringing out it was like
remember when ronald reagan got shot was
this at the cat when you stormed the
capitol
i didn't storm the capital i didn't
stone the capital and i'm gonna tell you
white people protest a lot different
than what the black people and i'm not
gonna make this podcast black and white
but that's what we do
but here's the story black people when
we protest we protest in the clothes
that we
head on we now take a break
in this incredibly charming effervescent
podcast
sparkling effervescent to um
i'm going to admit something to you to
talk about something just as sparkling
stephen
no you guys i need you to know that i am
i'm i'm
dating someone uh who was in a medical
school and i know you're dating someone
you told us
but i just found out that he has a
tremendous amount of student loans
and i didn't realize like dating a
doctor dating a vet everyone says it's
so great not till they're like 45
because he's 31 and he has i just
learned the amount of loans he has you
said why don't you start a podcast
i mean so the earnest uh
partnership we have uh has just become
very close to home and i actually will
be needing earnest very soon
um uh because it helps reduce student
debt it does it helps
refinance your loans into one little
flexible payment so if you're dumb and
thought it'd be a good idea to date a
specialized
vet who went to medical school for 10
years i have news for you you're going
to need
earnest we have to uh roll it up a tiny
bit sorry did i have news i have to read
a little bit about what it is i'm just
talking about my personal life
you can refinance your student loans
with earnest you can reduce your loan
term you can save money combine
multiple loans loans are a nightmare
they're confusing
so what did we learn here we learned
data human doctor
[Laughter]
go to earnest i'm going to be going to
earnest very soon so that this
relationship
uh doesn't get real sticky because
ernest will help you it'll put
everything in one place make it super
easy for you and right now earnest is
offering our listeners
a hundred dollar cash bonus refinance
your student loans
debt refund nope ernest is offering our
listeners a hundred dollar cash bonus
refinance your student debt at
earnest.com
whitney terms and conditions apply now
ernest is giving our listeners a hundred
dollar bonus refinance your student
loans at earnest.com
whitney terms and conditions apply once
again you get a 100
cash bonus when you visit earnest.com
whitney to refinance your student loans
not available in all states terms and
conditions apply
visit earnest.com whitney for more
details terms and conditions apply
earn a student loan refund do terms and
conditions apply i'm just curious
they do they do visit earnest.com
whitney for more details terms and
additions apply earnest student loan
refinancing made by earnest operations
llc
n m l s number one two zero four nine
one seven california financing law
license number six zero five four seven
eight eight
three zero three second street suite 401
north san francisco california nine four
one zero
visit earnest nine four one zero seven
you want me to do anything really good
no we just can't talk during the green
remember you can i mean
well i'm trying to read from that here
visit earnest.com licenses for a full
list of licensed assistances
all right if you guys know anything
about me you know that
uh when uh men are around me they get
e.d
let's be honest my voice is not an
aphrodisiac erectile dysfunction
uh is no stranger in my home uh and
it's frankly not fair to the lovers that
i take
so i have to do something to cancel out
my personality
so men can get arrested medication sorry
lobotomies weren't working so we had to
go to roman for help
and they are not allowed to murder me
anymore so we just have to make a deal
and roman's great because roman you can
get a free online evaluation and ongoing
care for your ed
all from the comfort and the privacy of
your home you can do everything from
your home nowadays
so you don't have to go be embarrassed
to go to write aid and ask some stranger
hey my dick doesn't work can i get a
pill you can go on the internet and tell
a stranger that a licensed healthcare
professional will work with you to find
the best
treatment plan if medication is
appropriate they will ship it to you for
free within two
shipping days it's appropriate trust me
get started
it's so simple just go to getroman.com
whitney and complete the online
visit and now we're going to read the
details uh
emily's going to read it because now
we're reading the important part of the
ads if we mess up one of us has to
play jelly bean roulette emily go
go to getroman.com whitney now you'll
get first
oh you did it on perfect because you
wanted a bean okay let's go
emily get a bean have it this is the
jelly beans that could be delicious or
could be awful
you took a blue one that's cheating
sorry what'd you get
blueberry bitch okay i'll try
blueberries both are good
ones toothpaste uh get go away
messed up
that was the first word and you messed
it up
i'm not doing st i'm not you don't know
because you don't know what colors they
are
shit hold on she just did a blue blue so
i don't know she did a
white one okay oh
i'm so traumatized oh what color is it
is the brown one oh god is it brown
oh i think i've covered again i can't
taste anything the chewing sound is
it's gross yeah oh yeah unless you like
it i can't
it doesn't taste like anything what is
it i don't know can we see that just
oh oh it's either chocolate pudding or
dog food oh
i i mean i'll just add go to get
roman.com
whitney now you'll get 15 off your first
month it's really time to take care of
your ed
and remember get started today and
you'll save fifteen dollars on your
first order of ed
treatment it's dog food go get boners
thank you
no listen listen like if i was gonna
protest right now i would be like let's
go
i wouldn't be like let's go to a costume
shop i need a bare skin rug
i need viking horns i need military
pants i need a pirate patch like i don't
know
shit fucking repellent cords i'm a
little worried that
was the was the outfit they were in
though no they got dressed up for that
they got a whole bunch
of it but it was i'm telling me has been
being a black person and
saying how white people uh look at black
people what they want to see
yeah it was so refreshing to see white
people scale a building
and i would say i know this is so dark
right i said to myself this is what you
think when you see crap i was like
somebody's gonna get shot i knew
somebody was gonna get shot
i knew somebody was gonna get shot but
the thing that made me feel so good i
knew the person that got shot wasn't
gonna be a black person
what a fucked up relief what a fucked up
thing to have to feel relieved that day
was so
ugly and what happened
was so disgusting and we're both from dc
i mean it was from the area it's so
awful like to see
what happened and then like the woman
who died
to me their cause was so ugly felt was f
was filled with so much anger
you don't want anybody to lose lose
their life but
it's a lot of people didn't give a fuck
yeah you know
it was a lot of people that was like
that's what you get yeah you know it's
unfortunate because anytime somebody
loses life you want to have some empty
you want to feel something but a lot of
people was just like dead and didn't
really give up there's so much pain at
this point
and there's so much callousness that
it's almost just like
we've gone so much goddamn hate
you know and like i tell people that
like
uh barack obama and trump they both
were almost the same person when i say
that they had
rock star quality right they had rock
star crowded they had energy they had
personality
and it came along at a time when people
were frustrated
over a lot of things people were
frustrated with the bush administration
so
motherfuckers even white people was
willing that's how you got elected was
willing to try
anything else and then it was an
underlining group of people
that supported donald trump that didn't
have a voice they were just waiting for
their superhero
to show up and and i tell people
both of those guys could have ran on
each other's campaign slogan when
obama was running he could have ran off
of i'm i want to make america great
again
right uh trump could have if you think
about it
and while if barack was ran off and make
america great again
trump could have came behind and ran off
a chain ran off and changed
mm-hmm we don't want that you know they
both had equality
they appealed to people they made people
feel good
but one of them the awful thing about it
it
came from a place of hate and what it
did was it just let
hate it just let hate build it let
hate grow and let hate manifest in
places it wasn't supposed to and i've
said this before
whatever you think uh trump accomplished
whatever
it doesn't matter if the uh he did good
with the economy
and some of the things that people say
he did it was just hard to root for him
yeah yeah yeah yeah
what i'm saying like yeah you like it i
don't know if i said this before but
like
in your situation you're a small
business right right in my situation i'm
a small business and i'm a veteran
so some of the things that he provided
for those two people
i could possibly say you know what uh
if he wins uh whatever these are things
i can take
uh i appreciate it i can appreciate but
the ugliness
is what made it so fucked up right and
it's and even when and
i'm gonna be real with it even like
everybody was like you got your
president with barack obama
people were happy no people weren't mad
people weren't mad at white people yeah
they weren't like fuck you
they wasn't dressing up they was fucking
happy that something that they waited
for for so many years
something that could inspire and
motivate them happened
hate's a drug self-righteous indignation
is a drug people are addicted to hate
it's it's it's wild to watch because i
don't think anyone wakes up in the
morning it's like i want to be hateful
and hate people i think they're
people are addicted to hate it makes
them feel important it makes them feel
meaningful like
it's just why would you choose that some
people i i've been in relationships
before right
right we all have and like and found out
some of them were talking to a point
like you know you have people that uh
they're not happy yeah unless they're
mad
they're addicted because you and when
they're mad that's a good
fucking day for them adrenaline
makes dopamine the same shit you get
from weed from heroin whatever it is a
drug when people start fights and
adrenaline they're recreating their
child
and then when i see people that hateful
do dopamine does that get anything
anything with sex or anything yeah yes
absolutely it's what you get when you
have an orgasm you get dopamine when you
what what is that thing when you choke a
motherfucker right before they bought
the bus one
uh the david carradine uh this ground
uh i can't say that where it's what is
it uh audio
audio autoerotic asphyxiation and this
is what i found through my years of
being
experimental i think dating by the white
woman
anybody that can pronounce that likes it
anybody and as a man i think that a man
should be able to choke a chick for
three mississippi
and if you're black you should be able
to do with a noose do it oh
start that's how it's gonna start in the
bedroom we're gonna get it we're gonna
get it back we're gonna connect
these cultures one fucking orgasm at a
time
that's where we need to connect no i've
never the thing is that at least
uh the white guys i've dated with uh
audio
they they try to choke you but they sort
of don't
go for it all the way so then you have
to act you have to be like
oh you got to make noise you got to
either do it or don't do it don't make
me
act do you have to like do like yeah
they'll kind of do it soft and you're
like
oh like what about is anybody ever like
so
is it is it it works better with a hand
or like what about it like a yeah
what about a whole wrap around what
about this like
like an arm bar yeah uh i i haven't had
one of the type of things that you
communicate when you have a woman in
this position i'm gonna do my guess and
what would you say
how would you communicate with her like
where like like if i had it like this
look at my face
uh you just say uh buy my lotion on
daniellerollings.com
no you gotta say shut the fuck up bitch
right you gotta say shut the fuck up
first
and then after you finish shutting the
fuck up then you buy the lotion
but you don't say it it's the craziest
thing a girl has ever asked for in bed
where you were like no i have a lot of
guy friends who are like they're asking
me to hit her
she's asking me to choke her and i don't
want to spit in my mouth
yeah yeah i've had that mm-hmm yeah what
is that
i don't know what it is i don't know
what it is but if you do it you
better not miss i got the spitting you
better not
you better not miss but when you're in
the mo think about it
when you like in the height
yeah and you're trying to get those
dwarf means popping yep
right dwarf means i like that yeah you
you
you have a in a groove so good
that you said something about your mind
why isn't anybody
filming this
i'm not just saying like you like oh
this
is the day why are we recording this
we need to archive this because i don't
know if i can reach
you never had that during sex yeah where
you in your mind you was like this fuck
i want to watch a playback of this it's
literally the only time i'm not being
filmed
it's like the only time you know what i
mean i'm like i don't know there are
times
where i've afterwards i guess taken
photos or something
to then send him later to try to keep
him to remind him like i did that thing
don't forget i did that crazy thing you
wanted me to do if there's like a
costume involved or something
after like he's gone did you take a
picture i mean like if i've dressed up
in a costume or done something wait a
minute you do that
like not like the q anons at the capitol
i'm not i'm not i'm not saying
that i i know you just but i'm that's
saying i know that you're in a
relationship and everything
but um there's a couple of posts you put
on instagram with different outfits
and in a community it's a phrase we use
oh she could get it
thank you yeah like like she could get
it
thank you it was the same thing with 50
cent connected with chelsea handler it's
like one episode
oh that bitch could get it thank you i'm
glad you're flattered by that but i'm
just saying
i was like and then you say stuff like
that i was like i knew there's a reason
i got you back for a second time on the
show
no you got me but you got me back on the
second time because
i had so much fun and you were so
awesome you know what i'm saying and
then at the time that i came in
you know and we still dealing with some
of those troubles
but i don't know it was a very very
testy time
and then we had to uh maneuver around
you know being responsible in the things
we said and being funny
this was literally the week after george
floyd like ten we were just trying to
have a really difficult
conversation uncomfortable conversation
and navigate it and it was so healing it
was great i i felt so good about i know
probably had some reservations about it
at first because he was like who am i to
say this but
like we talked about is that the only
way you can uh
get changed is you have to be able to
create dialogue anybody got to be able
to communicate with people without being
angry
and also that's like one of the great
thing about podcasts you can have long
three-hour conversations
to talk about a subject that could never
be discussed in eight minutes on a talk
show
i mean these are such complicated issues
so did the black squares work
is racism fixed yeah it's all over
good thank you i'm glad
we want motherfucking justice how much
two trillion all right we're all good
everybody everybody go home those signs
we could take those
we got it so the instagram worked no it
didn't check but i will say we talked
about it last time
i think uh people have a different look
on
how black people feel and even when we
talked about it we we've been through
so many situations where police have
wrongfully killed people
and and nothing really happened and you
felt like black people the only people
that were concerned about it
but i think the difference in this
situation with george floyd it felt like
the world was like fucking enough is
enough
right unfortunately we had to lose so
many lives for people to even get to
that point
but it was like everybody was fed up so
hopefully like moving forward like
you know people could have a better
understanding of how we feel and maybe
adjust some of the things that they do
and let me ask you a question and this
is i have this
was a specific incident i know you know
a couple people don't
represent all but i was on are you ever
going to try my lotion i am going to try
your lotion because
my like you realize white women's faces
go
i mean they get real dry real fast and
i'm 38 years old
i've moistened a lot of white faces
sorry what's actually in this lotion
i mean this you know that i'm like a
lotion horse i know
what i'm telling you then i'm about to
pimp you but can i put this on my face
but try it on your hands a little goes a
long way all right so don't go
oh that is a real thick yeah but that's
why you only need a little bit
oh what is that what is that coconut
pineapple
jungle female oh god that smells so good
it smells like
my hookups in college diaper tight belly
yeah get out get out there did i ever
tell you about the time did you use the
dude okay did you ever tell you the
first time i did a black guy
no that um i found uh thong underwear in
his bathroom and i was freaking out and
screaming
i found like sexy lingerie like in his
bathroom and i started screaming at him
and i was like who's this who's is this
and he was like that's my new rag
i'm so mad at you right now i'm so mad
and she was like
that's alert then i did it again i stand
corrected i accused him of cheating on
me because i started snooping through
his drawers
um why do women do that
do y'all stay out of my shoes okay why
do y'all have to flip your phone over
when you put it look at my phone right
now well why do you have to put nine
passwords on your phone
because you're trying to crack them yeah
but then why then just don't put them on
there and i won't try to crack it no no
women
yo i did just one girl once yo she was
so dope at cracking my password
right i changed my password and she
she's no i was about to change it and
she told me the code that i was thinking
about changing it to
i was like this relationship is over by
the way this is the most
this is the most moist cream i've ever
had like i'm like slipping around this
is telling you this is the most
moist cream i've ever had watch how long
it looks because my body sucks it up
right away cbd in it so like you got
uh inflammation or any of that type of
shit it just makes you feel good the
lotion makes sense
that is like because my i'm so what can
i get a little yes you do need a little
on that
i'm going to give you lotion so uh
uh and then the second time uh i could
be a foreign before and after
i accused him of uh why because okay it
had been fulfilled but you were young
but he was also a professional athlete
and he had a lot of shit in his head
you you yo basketball football i used to
have a big brother
football football i used to have a big
butt dunno right
yeah i mean you know i'm not like it's
not going to be like oh get me crazy i'm
a medium
medium yeah people my friends we never
have issues going out
yeah never i'd be like look at that girl
with that flat ass over there
look how flat my ass is after covered
but that's still a good one
look how flat it is that's what i call
that's a bathing suit it's not that that
is bad
that's like a lot i eat granola now that
ass is sufficient it's just a line like
i just have a legs
i can't do this i can't do this it's bad
i stalk lemon lulu places so don't do
this
lululemon or whatever okay so then i
accused the guy the same guy
cheating on me because yes he had a lot
of girls in his phone calling him he's a
professional athlete we weren't fully
together yet and i was trying to figure
out if we should be so i just was like
look i was looking for
shower gel in there
well no this was i was like 33 maybe 34.
yeah
this is like five years ago so he was a
professional like uh football uh
er okay the ones that run backwards at
the end defensive end the ones
um at the end okay i'm just going to say
just for anybody that's listening
that most professional athletes
get a lot of pussy yeah no shit they get
a lot of pussy
and if you're going to see if you try in
some cases they're faithful
it's going to be hard as shit to be an
athlete to be
rich to be popular and not
fuck and i was insecure also but i'm
going to tell you when
you got them like when they're in the
league here's the time if you really
want to get an athlete
you got to get them like two years after
retirement
interesting when they got all the cte
and the injuries but they don't got the
road schedule
yep they've done it they also they're
they're also easy
because they're so infantilized like if
you just like come in and like know
their atm code and start getting them
groceries they're
because they can't do anything for
themselves either so you just have to
show up and be responsible and then they
can't live without you
but okay here's my thing with women
doing investigations to crack codes and
everything and they finally crack the
code
and they find some incriminating shit
you'll always find what you're looking
for always always always
guess what almost
never does the relationship in
interesting
never and i this is what i thought and i
dated this chick once
and i was like and i wasn't
yo this is all funny to say i wasn't
doing anything crazy crazy right i only
had two side bitches
but i was wondering why i'm like this
chick is
trying so hard to catch me doing
something then come to find out
she was doing the same shit always so a
lot of times it's like this
they're projecting they want to catch
you is edible
no this is good lip balm it's everything
they want to catch you just so they can
justify
uh the things you're doing they're
projecting their guilt onto you
and yeah and another thing my thoughts
on cheating
for the most part men uh cheat for sport
and women cheat for revenge oh wow a lot
of women don't have
it in them to cheat but if it's like i'm
gonna get you back
fellas let me break it to you those girl
trips they're fucking
those girl trips when all you see is
pictures of all the girls
they're fucking i mean you got another
month until the vaccine comes out
as soon as that vaccine's out they're
probably back to it you got another
month to where they're not cheating on
you are you doing a vaccine
uh hold on i'm about to watch you drink
soy milk let's see how this goes
i just i just want to protect my my shit
here
because i just this is expensive
technology
chocolate soy mocha it tastes good oh
good
right it's kind of sweet soy milk so
there's no sugar
it's a lot of sugar really but it's just
soy milk is naturally kind of sweet and
then the mochi chocolate
yeah mocha uh-huh so you don't think
that that's a racist order
the soy like did you feel good when you
was like chocolate mocha
that's just me back to fucking
dude
this was the straw that broke the
camel's back of he i went through his
shit
i was going through his drawers right
because i was just gonna see because i
was like he's got another girlfriend
he's got something else going on
sure enough i find a a drawer with a
pair of diamond earrings and i'm like
who's our whose are these whose earrings
are these and he was like those are mine
and i was like oh right what the fuck is
wrong black guys wear
diamond earrings yo what the fuck is
wrong with you
what the fuck is that's a fucking show
right there trying to catch somebody
being black i'm gonna catch you being
black watch
yeah i was like what is this a white
dude
you would have been cheating this would
have been some other woman's jewelry and
then
the thing that was the worst i was like
okay you have diamond earrings got it
sorry i got it now
and then valentine's day that was a fuck
that was gonna be fucked up you found
diamond emma's in the drawer i know
i'm never gonna find him in the drawer i
was like this must be someone some girls
who left it here right and then
valentine's day comes and i'm like oh
this is i'm going to get some diamond
earrings he knows jewelers i got little
gold balls
i was like no you so you get the diamond
earrings and i get the gold balls
um i like this one relationship lasted
how long
uh like five or six months first the
first
black guy you dated no was it no
i thought this is not the first story
the first story oh gosh that was the
first story
no the first story i'm just the first
one going on the rails
crossed the tracks or whatever right and
and they were like uh
they were like trying to get their
girlfriends to do it like it's like one
starts it off right i don't know
then they talk it up it's like what did
you do it you do it you do it because i
think so they're gonna do it
it's too much curiosity the first time
was it everything that they talked about
oh interesting i don't know i don't know
but um
that's a good question i've heard a lot
of epic fails really yeah i've heard
something like wasn't everything that
you were talking about
well you know what the thing is that
actually was the the the part that was
like
it was actually wild because to see
racism
happen like in a way or like oh fuck
like because everyone's staring at you
so you did this you were so back then
when you did it black guy you were
a freedom fighter and it was a freedom
fuck um i didn't i'm just saying
i didn't think of it that way you gave
him some peace corps
i basically was i basically went to
dancing with the stars and i was with
chelsea handler
and he oh you don't have to say anything
else let me tell you something about
best fans best fiends
when i was little i used to carry around
a cape everywhere a wizard cape
i was going to be a wizard but now best
fiend it's in my pocket at all times
so look at this best fiends is your
replacement for dressing up as a wizard
in public yes look at my little team
and we we're fighting slugs let me see
hold on but wait it's so fun you just
get to like i have to connect these
little
strawberries and then it makes my little
scorpion shoot the slug
it's so cute i love it and then you can
level them up i'm literally obsessed
with loving them up because they change
outfits they look different as they grow
i know but why am i why can't i get
these raindrops going i get stuck on the
raindrops
well this is the very first level so
let's just to redouble he's green
so you have to use green oh cutie
he's leaves but so look when you touch
this thing the little guy smiles that's
so cute i'm obsessed best fiends just
puts me in such a good mood it's like
this puzzle game it's a mental puzzle
game but it's like
there's so many characters there's so
many different ways to win it's
really i mean honestly i've been playing
it since i'm obsessed with it at this
point i think it's the only time when i
go to my phone it's the only time i do
something healthy for myself
my phone now i associate with like
negative texts
uh bills you know bad news
and so like you're like on online
shopping and buying a bunch of stuff i
don't need like this is my like healthy
app on my phone that i don't know it's a
good way to just like check out
and not hurt myself and not spend money
work your brain yes
without being like on your phone doing
nothing yes yes totally
and it just makes me feel like i'm
giving my brain extra a lot of my
friends in nashville play it too and
then we'll send each other screenshots
of like who has more points who's got
more slugs
more who's leveled up they're a little
critical i'm past level one now so i'm
catching i'm obsessed with it
i'm catching up with you i'm getting all
right you're getting there um it's free
to download it's
best fiends um you can match three it's
a casual
mobile puzzle game very fun look at it
i'm just showing i really can't put it
down i love it um a hundred million
downloads
a hundred million dollars 100 million
people download this that's crazy it's
amazing um
download best fiends free today on the
apple app store or google play that's
friends without the r best fiend you had
a practice on that one that wasn't fair
what's two sentences lazy
lazy for feeling blue that's me when i'm
out of brooklyn and
lazy the problem is i don't need more
reasons to stay in bed all day
well brooklyn is not helping at all
beautiful high quality bedding and home
essentials they work directly with
manufacturers to give you a fair price
no middlemen no markups i got to be like
sheets have gotten
so exorbitant and i think it's they know
that we're all home and bedridden and
sick or something they're jacking up
prices and their comforters their
comforters are but not brooke
their comforters come in lightweight all
season and
ultra warm to suit every type of sleeper
if you run cold if you run hot if you're
just a regular person
or you like to turn yourself in a
burrito like benton yeah i i like to i
like to
ice out the house and then roll up in a
blanket you know what i like to do
we'll see and then slide down the stairs
oh
it's really fun you can do it so far
yeah
i mean be safe guys there's also they
also offer a variety of materials
including an eco-friendly recyclable
down alternative love that there's a
reason that brooklyn has over 75
000 five-star reviews and counting and
also by the way i know that this is in
the copy but we also use brooklyn and
towels oh the towels are great
but they sent us some and we i spilled
so much stuff in the podcast studio
when paris hilton was on that look and
it absorbed it all look at this
what about the loungewear have you tried
the loungewear but no
give it to me loungewear is my whole
life so comfortable look at this
i i put so much makeup on this and then
it washes right out this is the only
towels that the makeup
it doesn't look like super absorbent
really easy to clean they're very soft
treat yourself to the ultimate comfort
with brook linens comforter collection
go to brooklyn.com and use promo code
whitney to get 25
off with a minimum purchase of a hundred
dollars that's b-r-o-o-k-l-i-n-e-n.com
and intro promo code whitney for 25
off with a minimum purchase of a hundred
dollars that's brooklyn.com
promo code whitney damn i was trying to
distract you the way we used to do
basketball and people did free throws
i didn't play basketball so i know how
to i know how to ignore jocks how you
like that
i'd probably have way less pregnancy
scares if i did too cut
well you know we were doing a summer
camp chapel show summer camp
and chelsea came out and then during the
summer camp i became the river ninja yep
you know you know that part right i do i
got in touch with nature
i started doing earthing and grounding
getting in touch with my
chakras in earthing and grounding that's
when you're standing barefoot on the
dirt and receiving the sort of
electricity from the ground for your
ions to be balanced yeah that's
everything and that's grounding yeah
then they have another thing that's a
combination of earth and ground it's
called
sun eating oh right and nasa did a study
on it
the the health benefits and what what
the combination of what you do is like
you get you get in touch with the ground
barefoot right then you got to walk
somewhere where you can see the sun
right right and then you like you're
supposed to look at the sun
not not when it's uh like when it's
fully out there i feel like that's a
perverted thing to say well not when you
don't look at when it's fully out
right but like when it's coming up and
you add 10 seconds every day it's a
it's a practice where after a
certain period of time your eyes get
used to it right
and it can help you with your diet it's
so many things because it sets your
clock and also you get that vitamin d
which everyone's talking about
exactly for your immune system but do
you know that you've got that vitamin d
but do you know that the the the way to
get the most
uh sun and vitamin d the fastest is
through your butthole
and people are stunning their body guess
what that's why black people have
a vitamin d deficiency
that's one vitamin fuck that well i'm
not doing that
you open your butthole up look at that
oh this is
to this one yo first up how did you even
what was the conversation that happened
where
who said it i know it's somebody like
this oh you really want to know how to
get that vitamin d
really through your butthole through
your butthole so if you if you're like i
need to be out in the sun for an hour
today to get vitamin d or whatever
if you just put your butthole to the sun
for like five minutes because the skin
is so thin and you
get more i believe is the logic the next
question my question for you is
how much vitamin d have you had lately
in my butthole in your butthole anyway
anywhere period
people uh uh uh affiliated with uh
people uh the woman goes by metaphysical
she's a big fan of what pla
perineum perineum is that how you
pronounce it perineum stunning
30 seconds of sunlight on your asshole
per day is the equivalent of a full day
of sunlight with your clothes on the
benefits
more energy better sleep uh more
creativity more sexual energy i don't
know if your butthole is sunburned how
good can the sex be
it's hard for me to even know when i'm
sunburned yeah
i'm telling you i did some dumb ass shit
i was like this i said to myself
black people don't get sunburned that's
what i said me my friend we were in
naples florida
when our friends had a boat went on a
boat and we was like because when you go
like when you spend like time in new
york
wherever you go somewhere down south
where son you want to come back with a
tan
yeah let people know i've been on
vacation so we didn't know anything
about um
fps's or c what's that this spf yeah the
number that regulates what type of
uh sunscreen you would have right like
spf or
uv yeah yeah it has like a number tattoo
yeah but a lot of those are fake
apparently now they go to like a hundred
and eighty apparently it doesn't really
matter there's no
thing about it we grew up on baby oil
yep we had tin foil and baby oil and we
got this
we was like this we coming back i'm
coming back with a new name they're
gonna call me chocolate buddha
when i come back i put that baby on we
was on that goddamn boat for like five
hours
and i was like oh shit the next day no
it dried my my shit was tight my neck
was tight
i was a i was a cinnamon color i was
like a brown and a red and that shit was
painful i was we didn't think it could
happen yeah
you know because you so you just learned
that yeah i just learned it
again yeah but it was like it was it was
awful experience but i love that you
um i feel like i watched it kind of
happen with you when you were out
um uh at dave's in nature like
do you feel like you've like reconnected
like or connected
i didn't feel like
hollywood was alive for so many years i
feel like
the energy and the vibe they create
created here is like you have to be
here to make hollywood yeah you know and
they want you to be scared and need them
yeah for the most part that was the case
when i first started doing it
but because of podcasts because of
virtual this and virtual that
you realize that it doesn't have to be
here
and like when i first when i did it was
at a time where
you know it was stress in my
relationship or whatever fuck you want
to call it
um i hadn't told jokes in a while i
really loved the community out in yellow
springs dave chappelle and the whole
crew
and i just needed to fucking get away
you know what i mean just get away not
run away but just get away
and when i went out there i started
realizing
how simple life could be yeah
you know what i'm saying like when i
used to be like not that i'm a fashion
person like that when i used to be like
oh i need these new shoes new shoes
i think i was like this i just need a
pair of fucking tivas that's it
i just need a pair of tv i went from
adidas to tv's
i went from the streets to the creeks i
went from the hoods
to the woods i went from oars to whores
yo whitney
i became a
river ninjas yeah and i wasn't mad at it
yeah it was simple shit like finding
peace in the river yeah
it was just like you don't need this
like where you know hollywood muffler
you think you need 34 belts and shit
no when you're in the fucking midwestern
you fucking rivers you need one fucking
belt
and one of the ones with the little
loops on it yeah yeah you know what i'm
saying it could be used for anything you
could pull a tractor out of a ditch if
you need
it can hold your pants up you know what
i'm saying you could pull it
whatever that's i was finding out that
it's in this
city i never thought that i would be
excited about seeing the marshalls
dude marshall's is the shit what i'm
telling you marshall's has it all
tj maxx is is do you remember filing's
basement i remember that dude that was
that was my
shit but the reason why i never thought
i'd be excited about it because when i
was growing up
this is where i grew up going to
marshalls going to tj maxxl's place it
represented you didn't have enough money
to go to other places okay
so once you get some money i go to other
places you forget that
uh in marshalls everything is 1999. yeah
they got one price for any
fucking thing you want in there durag
1999.
diamond earrings 19.99 butthole plugs
19.99 they might be in the dvd bin
but they're 1998. they're gonna be right
now but it just felt like
it just it felt like such a connection
and i remember
uh the day when i really felt like i was
gonna become the river ninja
i was dry i was i was a man um on the
mad river
shout out to my dude ted the greek ted
greek whatever the fuck it is
um i was in the mad river and one of my
friends been known for here patrick
we're both in different kayaks right i'm
in one he's in one
and we're smoking a joint right and then
we just it was just you could just
hear like birds water and it was just so
peaceful we were just chilling
and then he said he said danielle this
is what life is all about
he said this reminds me of uh building
bike ramps in the backyard and going
crawdad fishing
with my dad i was like well you wanted
on this one because i didn't do none of
that shit with my dad
but i felt what he was saying about the
simple things in life
and and in that moment some it just made
me think of the things
that memories that my dad didn't create
with me and that how bad i wanted
to share those experiences
with my son and how simple it is you
know i'm saying we so caught up on like
kids kids oh they cook to their
computers they're hooked to their phones
a lot of that's because um that's the
easiest option to give them
you know myself are you fishing with
them are you taking them to hike and
people complain and they don't give them
another option
they don't give another option and my
son like he's on he's just like any
other kid like the youtube videos or
whatever
but when i take him out and when he
finally came out
when i took him out of nature it wasn't
about that phone it was about
skipping rocks because it's also my
thing is my phone's super addictive and
compelling until i go into nature and i
don't have a desire to even look you
don't want to do it you know
i mean you want to you don't want to
look at it but you know you for some
reason
we are a society that we feel like we
feel like we have to capture
every moment we don't want to you we
don't want to tell a story
we don't want to be like you know when
we were coming up uh
and i'm some different age but it was
like this you had to see the story and
you had to have the person who knew how
to
share the story that's right and that's
the only way and when you saw them
whitney you was like this
yo you know everybody remember that time
with the backyard there was no let me
just show you let me show you
you had to tell an amazing fucking story
uh you know you didn't just get to go
here's the video right
and you had and then as as that story
grew over the years
it always changes always always you
embellish
when you're in that story like wait a
second you were in jamaica i thought you
were in van nuys no no it's different
and then you have to get more especially
for my community yeah like
when we tell a story it's very
animated like if i like if i tell a
story like you could be like
you would tell stories you'd be like
donald i was walking down the street
you know and a guy pulls me over and i
got upset i couldn't say it like that i
was like
whitney i'm walking down the street you
know what i'm saying i'm walking
you got to you got to be like this how
was you walking okay let's do it you got
to keep asking
me okay then what happened yo so i'm
walking down the street right okay
okay which okay were you roller skating
no i wasn't roller skating i was just
walking
it's been times where i rolled up okay
all right but it wasn't that that day
i'm okay regular walking okay
okay then like when you change the
direction i'm walking then
then boom boom what happened who you saw
someone no boomer's not a gun yeah i saw
boom i saw him boom yeah i'm like come
over here so then i stroll strollers
walking too okay then i stroll over and
i say what's up i give him a high five
you know what i'm saying you gotta act
yes
yeah there was no we we you were i mean
when you were
we were telling stories and shit before
social media you had to be
uh entertaining right people stopped
learning to be entertaining anymore
people
here look at my phone and by the way
i've i've talked like in some of these
youtube stars when you talk to them
you're like oh you've only been doing
this for a screen
like you don't know how to do it to
people yeah they don't know how to beat
you know you don't know how to keep
people's attention necessarily in a live
situation that's the only thing the only
issue i have with the social guys that
claim to be comedians whatever
let's just be good at both of them yeah
yeah you know i mean the fact that you
have a platform where you can
it doesn't matter what anybody say about
the social media communities or whatever
um these people that like they they're
self-made
they're doing they're adapting they're
adapting to it that's what we would be
doing if we were 25
we would do the same thing and you know
no matter what you think of like
how they get their path to success they
got there you know and
and they got there on their own will you
like with those videos and those guys
do this shit every day this shit is
draining you know how hard it is to be
consistent with this it's exhausting
it's exhausting but they know what to
pay off
they know how to use dropbox i have all
the respect in the fucking world for you
you know
but they're also i think teaching us
like these social media comedians
they're teaching us and showing us like
you know you guys don't have to do it
the old way you fucking old f you don't
have to go do
50 cities and then shoot an hour like
you can yeah but the oldest people are
so
they want to be so angry because they
see the success these people are doing
with less time instead of embracing it
you know i mean they're showing us like
you can do a little five minute clip i
was watching your shit this morning the
oprah thing and
would you have done this had social you
had not seen like oh other
you can do this yeah this is donnell
doing an interview with oprah smashing
oakland sebastian rawlings very cool
and this on air excerpt the duchess of
ashiness talks publicly
for the very first oh hold on i'm about
his father
when did you do this how fast did it
take to turn this around he found out
his dad was working with the towel it
took us
did it feel like betrayal when you found
that your father was
working with a tabloid betrayal what you
think what kind of question is that
do i think it was betrayal you goddamn
right it was betrayal
it was betrayal sherelle
michelle and betrayal this bitch just
asked me
do i think it was motherfucking betrayal
what do you think it was
he said no absolutely not he hadn't been
talking to him so he basically lied to
you
yeah he lied to me he lied not basically
the motherfucker lied what you trying to
figure out
betrayal sick every time i fucking talk
to you
fucking making the nigga cry
yes he lied to me oprah winfrey
ask me something else ask me something
your father
being hunted down it seemed like you
were saying in some ways that
they did this to him so i want you to be
able to clarify this that
that the tabloids the media did this to
him they hunted him
but he has a responsibility in it too
his responsibilities didn't give his
motherfucking kids
yes the tabloids was hunting him so was
my mother was hunting him
the the weed nigga was on him the
laundry nigga was hunting
everybody was hunting him because he
wasn't shit does that answer your
question
he was being haunted by everybody
police and did his side bitches
your half-sister on your father's side
has written a
a supposedly tell-all book about
you what is what is your relationship
with her i don't fuck with the bitch
how about that go run and tell that tell
our book
i don't fuck with the bitch i have such
a quarter sister
i don't give a fuck i don't fuck with
the bitch and she can get her money she
want
i get my money should you writing books
you writing books
i'm selling low shit bitch i'm selling
motherfucking lotion
the whole family can get paid i just
don't appreciate
all this shit so you all weren't close
she didn't grow up together
yeah we grew up together but i didn't
fuck with the bitch
she doesn't really know you i see her
like
holidays and stuff like that but i ain't
fucked with a bitch i didn't i mean she
was cool she was my sister but i didn't
really fuck with like that and she was
always a prime yes
bitch she was grimy and i used to
spend time in the palace i used to be up
in here
and it was good it was good the
relationship we had
now they want to just see that's that
white people shit
now i'm nobody
just because i'm passionate so
were you thinking of harming yourself
were you having suicidal thoughts
bitch no i wasn't suicidal i was
ashy okay did you know what ashley is
take your shirt off right now i mean
telling oprah to take her
take your face off right now
let me see the motherfucking ankles
oprah
do you know how that feels i'm telling
you
people can't associate
ash with black and i'm telling you
i'm 100 sure the reason they kicked me
out
and don't have anything to do with me
is because i'm first of all
where are you you got to wait wait wait
wait wait wait why are there so many
burns in the background
i was passionate what did you go over
here
what what are you hard of hearing what
did you hear me yes and you're not going
to tell me who had the conversation
no i'm not telling you shit go ask gayle
bitch
y'all talk a lot fuck you ask me a
question with girl got all the got their
answer to the questions
can you can you tell us what the
question was i'm not saying shit
go ask your bff i'm not saying here
dude where are these birds where are
they oh
the funny thing about that is every so
often it's up now on donnell's instagram
you guys this is so
fucking funny but the thing about it was
like
yo you know i came from a sketch
background and people are always like
when you gonna do more schedules
but it's kind of i don't think sketch
yeah but every so often
shout out to my the guy that helped me
put that together it's
awes 10 minutes beautifully edited
perfectly
like you turned around that in 24 hours
it was really less than 24 hours like
we already know like if there's ever
like a really dope news story
like how can we comment on it yeah and
it's like it's so funny come on my god
samson
it's like we've been trying to put a
project together you know sometimes you
force stuff it doesn't happen
and then the light bulb the light bulb
went off with him
and then when it went off for him with
him it went with me
but this is the dope shit like i really
appreciate about his efforts
it's like no we go there we try to do
everything one time he laid everything
out
he had the editor yeah he had everything
keyed out yeah
and then this one i knew he was serious
because you know how you put a sketch
like that
you want a certain voice to voice it
yeah but you put another voice in there
just for placement
right right right you don't stand so you
can yes yes yes like places it look like
like from the time that he thought about
the idea i think
at his place maybe an hour after that
maybe two hours after that and the the
the
shit that i had to record i did that in
like
20 minutes he was editing and
probably like an hour after that it was
ready to rock if this was
i mean back it when we used to make
television like a sketch would take
200 people between the crew the lawyers
the writers the you know the
that means a lot of people might be out
of jobs in some ways as this business
changes but this is two people takes 24
hours this is how it should be for
something like this
and his content but that no notes no
executives telling you you can't say
that you can't
that's what it is no fear no don't don't
come for oprah no fear
that's what i was like when i was i was
looking at it
and i was like oh i called over a bitch
four times i was like
okay snoop diddle she would have thought
it would be hilarious
yeah of course you know gayle would have
well i don't think maybe not caleb
gail might be in the comments like why
funny story about gayle so first time i
met i was doing some shows with
chappelle in new york right
and uh she saw my show we were at this
place where we were getting a little
little uh
appetizers and stuff and she came sat
beside me
right and she was like hey daniel you're
so funny you're so funny
and i'm like and i'm saying to myself oh
shit man
that's oprah friend you know you take
her name away from me
oprah is so huge but you know somebody
that's oprah
and then i had my phone uh i had my
phone right here
and she was like i got to get your
number i said okay i put my phone on
and she tried to look at my phone i said
i said i said
don't look at my phone you you and then
i'm talking little shit i'll say yo you
ain't ready for this is my phone she
said i'll see your phone
she engaged and she said what's in your
phone i said don't worry about it
then she said are you on instagram
i said that's kind of an insulting
question for me to be in the field and
ask someone
she said okay give me your instagram i
gave my instagram and she got her
glasses right here right
and she's looking she got a glasses like
this right and she's looking like
scanning through stuff and i had did
this video michelle k had this video
called
you can't um you can't um raise a man
right mm-hmm and i thought that was very
insulting
especially for me being a man i was like
it was like my i said i need to do an
answer to it so i did a song said you
can't save a bitch
if you can't raise man you can't say
bitch right and i dressed up like this
preacher he had tim's
shit on everything and i had just posted
on my page so she was looking she was
like
what is this and this when i started the
organization save a bitch.com
right okay and the reason why it might
not be there anymore but the reason
you forgot to pay your go daddy yeah
that's probably what it was yeah your
squarespace
i let it go i didn't do anything with it
so it was um she was like
she was like what's the name of the
organization this is what it goes to by
the way
oh shit is that it no no somebody
probably snatched it it was years ago oh
shit so she was like what is i was like
i gotta um i said this is what i broke
down to i said listen
i i'm an activist i got this
organization and i said this is what i
said
i said i think all women at a certain
age right
at certain age they have two things on
the scale temptation
and salvation okay and depending on who
comes your life
it could tip the scale either to
temptation and salvation interesting
i said so i started this organization
to save and help in that
area right she said oh darnell she was
like she's a daniel
that's such a wonderful idea and she was
like what's the name of the organization
and i said okay before you
get upset or anything just understand
that this is for
women's source so and she said what's
the name of it
and i said save a bitch.com
she did like this she said oh no
she said i said i'm saying to myself i'm
not never known
i'm never going to meet oprah i'm like
it's over it's over i can't get in i
can't get with steadman i'm like
if oprah knows i use bitches to send
this i'm never going to get to the bitch
right listen so i said you calling her
bitch probably isn't helping me either
but yeah
yeah but she was like she's like oh no
and it looked like her face oh no oprah
and i are going to talk about this right
she was like oh no but she didn't
understand and she was like
she didn't let me get to the part where
i explained why i said because when you
trying to start something
my intent was very clear right what i i
did i
how are you gonna do i said by letting
them uh explain women that
you know be secure with yourself you
know i really had a plan for it
but i needed people to get connected
with it and i was like i could have been
like
you wanted to be on oprah's favorite
things right i was like i could have
been like
save a queen nobody like man everybody
want that shit but
like i was like if i call it save it
bitch be like oh who was a bitch
but then once i pulled you in didn't
change and my mother i even
asked my mother about it and i told her
what the organization was and i hit her
with the name of it
and and my mother always trying to look
for different um she was like
did she talk to a girlfriend she would
rescue a bitch no no no she said
let's change the acronym and let's
change the definition of it
let's make it an acronym and call it
bitch being in total control of herself
oh so i said
listen over bitch listen are you in
control of yourself
but that was weird and i thought that me
and uh
gail would never see eye to eye on
anything else
but because she's a close friend of
chappelle she's always been a vince and
we we
sit back and we laugh at it but she
didn't play
she didn't we got it we got to get this
uh this uh lotion on oprah's favorite
things
you know what and i want to get into i
want to get into a daytime space
you'd be incredible at it i need a link
like i want to get into it so much that
i reached out to ricky lake the other
day
okay i love reading i love ricky lake
and i grew up on ricky lake
do you know how she has said so much
trauma in her personal life
i know i did i used to do the show years
ago when it was when you remember when a
lot of shows were going to like we want
a panel of different people with
different perspectives
and everything and i was it was kind of
the first podcast in a way yeah you know
she was having on you know regular
people to talk about their drama people
don't know it's so funny about this
industry
people want you to be hot your entire
career that's right but people don't
understand it's like
and like with ricky you know this
whitney you got we could be in this shit
for like
20 years or whatever right and it could
be like two or three years where you
just kill them
yep two or three years where you're in
the most demand
your two a day city or whatever you
might not be able to maintain that
forever
but you got those three years where you
can get it popping ricky lake had about
nine or ten of them and then sometimes
you gotta go away
and and grow and and and sometimes you
gotta not do the same shit
sometimes you're like i've had it i
wanna do something else i'm no longer
interested in this a lot of times when
you go away people like where have you
been what happened you're like
well i tried to have a personal life
because in order for art to imitate life
you have to have a life so i can't have
good jokes unless i go on dates and have
life
yeah and that's how it was like that's
how it was even to this point right now
the other day i said to myself i thought
i'd never say this
and i wouldn't i thought i'd never say
this because all the money i ever made
it was dependent on doing
road gigs right i thought i'd never say
this whitney that you know what
i'm not upset that i'm not doing a lot
of comedy right now yeah
and the reason why i'm not because the
pandemic forced me to pivot yep
and i realized i said okay you got
donald you got to look at life as if
suppose you never do a live show again
what the fuck are you going to do
and as much people make fun of me with
uh some of the
products or whatever i'm trying to do
but i was like everyone makes fun of
everyone yeah they do
and they say whatever he talking and
shit whatever but i said you know what
yeah yes we are yes i am
i said but i know i had to make a pivot
because i didn't want to have to rely on
just touring to make money
and one reason i want to do that because
i'm an older guy with a young son i want
to spend more time with my son i want to
have to be out every weekend
so when i first started i first started
with the candles and you had to count
the candles the black ash candle
was someone not only we ordered more
someone took
them uh uh who was it that took someone
like literally was like i'm taking this
with
one of our guests i'll try we just had
one but we'll get more but
what would the whale come in my point um
what is the whale goddamn fucking what i
forgot
we had what was that shit the black ash
amber
ambergris hamburgers that sounds like a
chick out dated but you know
it sounds like a off of coffee on the
starbucks ambergris
double latte ambergris
it's in the black ash candle and smells
like the the point i was making was
so i started with the candle shit
because i was like okay daniel what are
you gonna do because you know when this
is when you
did that candle did well right the
candle did well and it's like
the most exciting thing about it for me
was like um
when because i have a shopify app you
know how nice
so like when you hear the ding you know
it's a sale
i felt like a only fan's whore
oh shit give me that motherfucking
candle and then i started i started
pushing it i started pushing it
and you know rogan rogan is the king guy
yeah
you know it's called the rogan bump and
thank you again for letting me talk
about my candle last time
because i had a lot of sales because of
that why women love candles i know they
do
and guess what else white women uh-oh
you have river ninja coffee now
holy shit this is gonna go so well with
my oatmeal
yo outside and like coconut sugar i'm
telling you the streets
are on flight i love you come
on but also here's the thing you know
that the blue collar comedy guys you
know them
yeah i i was working with in austin we
were doing a residency around
ron white is oh fucking love that guy so
much they're the nicest guys in the
world nothing bad to say about any of
them
but i remember reading that um larry the
cable guy was making 380
uh uh 300 380
000 a month on beef jerky alone just put
his name on it they were in gas stations
like
when i tell you river ninja river ninja
river
ninja is like i'm gonna tell you another
thing that got me inside i'm going to
fucking build that brand to it's like
the paul newman
starbucks please river ninja replace
starbucks
we could do it i don't call it star fox
yup
and all the coffee is black
and eddie murphy could be an investor
been called star fox and
call back to that snl drama you want the
dark roast or what
uh i'm just saying i'm going to smell it
because i love to smell coconuts but
it's also like
why the fuck not like i had shame about
selling merch and stuff i was like oh
god do people think i'm corny i'm like
you know what i felt the same if you
think i'm corny fine
fine but here's the thing though whitney
with that said and i i dealt with that
but i was like
you can be corny if you're selling
somebody a quality product and you know
what the people who think you're corny
are probably
people that aren't going to buy shit
anyway yeah exactly they're like comics
that are jealous because they wish they
could do it
you know what i'm saying but it was just
like i was in uh target the other day
i was entirely the other day and then uh
i went through i was
in the salad dressing i saw paul newman
face on everything
and then i went to like the pets uh
aisle because i have a pup
and fucking paul newman dog treats i was
like
why why why can't i do that if i can
like if i continue to give people
quality stuff like even with the lotion
it was for years i've never been more
moist in my life
oh shit that can all change that's right
give me the sailboat that can all change
never been that moist in your life look
at this and this is fancy trying to get
that whop
by the way this everything is wet except
my pussy right now
i do need to get this but uh aqua i love
that this is it's
uh aqua in princess purified water you
get this is
where it is this is what i'm saying for
years people like you need to get a
lotion you was actually i was like
i didn't want to do it for the i know i
could get a sale off the novelty of it
mm-hmm but i wanted something like
you know i wanted to you didn't want to
cheat and people are coming back
everybody
that has used that fucking love to shit
i mean
they they live they live and i actually
think comedians are the people you
should trust the most because we're the
ones that are the most critical
of other people's corny shit you know
like i mean when we go through the merch
i'm like we can't put this out like it's
not good enough yet it's not like i
don't wanna
you know get killed on this when i see
other people's shitty merch i'm like why
are you selling this to people they're
going to buy it and you're selling them
garbage yeah but that's what the people
who are thoughtful about it yeah because
you want the product because
you your brand comes in people
respecting and you have to have
integrity and like all of the products
that i've put out
it's like i'm like oh i could look i can
get a quick dollar that's true but i
still i want people to come back
you know what i mean i want people to
enjoy that what's also also what's wrong
with that
it's also not a quick dollar you put a
ton of time and energy into this now i'm
just saying like i could have
i could have done this with not as much
very good ingredients i could have done
this with cheaper labor i could have did
cheaper rabbit i was like let me try to
make it as premium as possible then
people
respect it but all of this all of these
things these ideas
was born out of my escape from hollywood
going into yellow springs
having that experience and just getting
those fucking energies
and i'm telling you that this summer was
one of the and sometimes i feel
bad by saying it but when like a lot of
people this summer wasn't good
but i'm telling you it was one of the
financially it wasn't
but in terms of like i said to myself
suck the year up
plant seeds for next year yeah so i'm
starting to see that shit
it was good it was good for my mental it
was good for everything
and even with us and i know people
heard the stories of because i've been
rocking with dave yellow springs
no people heard the stories of austin
with us
creating a bubble yeah and then the
bubble being breached
yeah you know it happened and i think
that you've had a similar situation
but i had coveted i got it hard as shit
yeah but you know
one thing okay it's one thing to have
covet
right and then people a lot of times
people don't know how they got it yeah
but in some cases people get it
trying everything to have a normal
life right and get back as i say get it
honestly
get get it honestly because i've seen
i've seen you like
you making your pivot feel like what the
fuck i'm doing i'm standing i'll do
shows to doing the shows here
to like feeling comfortable with the
fact that
i have the resources to be able to test
people
know their status and you did something
similar to
what chappelle did the whole summer up
into a month ago
like how can i be
as normal as possible yeah and get my
life because with the physical
drawbacks and things that can happen to
you with um in a pandemic
the mental could be crazy too dude the
suicide rates are up like loneliness
they're now showing could actually be
worse for you than coveted you know i
don't
i'm not a scientist like but you know i
think there were a lot of comedians like
to me i felt
you know the obligation after i saw what
chappelle was doing to be like i have
space
i can do this like i can let's try it
dave said it on that last
that that that special uh the last thing
you put on specials commentary
serious points a little joke he said he
was like
and he was like people love to see a
hero
fall yep they rejoice
yeah he was like because i watched him
tape this four times because that's the
last piece
the last piece was like the last piece
was part of um
what he started about don't watch
chappelle show yeah until
they paid me my money when i tell you
that whole thing was how that transpired
because i remember one day this is one
of my closest friends right
and i saw three looks in his eyes and i
saw the look in his face
i don't know what he said
i'm about to stick these motherfuckers
up i'm like what the fuck you talk about
i don't know it's a good thing to say
for a black guy stick he said he said
they're gonna give it to me
or i'm gonna take it wow didn't
understand what he was saying
didn't understand what it meant until
i was backstage when he made he did the
first video and did the first video
he explained was going on and there were
some people like these people it was
some people backstage
that were nervous those people that have
to depend on people
yeah accepting them or whatever and they
were like this they were
this is a black man and they were like i
think uh
he might be taking the black stuff a
little too far
and i said to myself nope i said this is
something that's been on his mind
forever
and when that's the case everything he
said is coming out is coming from a true
place whatever he said that
dropped the mic by the way take it too
far
he should take it too far yeah but some
people don't want to be yeah they don't
want to
like the pushback so when he made that
announcement and everybody's okay i
wonder what's going to happen
i wonder what's going to happen and then
he did the next one when uh
he didn't want to talk about how he got
how he got the money
but i was with him and by the way at the
same time i i don't know if this is
a tantamount thing but taylor swift was
taking back her catalog of music and she
was like a hero
yeah because both of those folks did
some shit that nobody ever does
nobody you know what it is you sign a
contract that's it they own it and
people were saying like you should
whatever you signed a contract but like
you said
i didn't know what i was signing i
signed up as a kid your kid this first
thing you put
who had a debt and no you know
uh money no health insurance which
choice did i have then when he said um
and i was i was with him he he planted
to see
and i was with him when the call came in
when
and we were just hanging out and he was
on the phone he said
got him and i was trying to read his lip
on how much
all right it was a noise chuck
but got him and he felt vindicated not
just for the money but the efforts and
how dare you do this
because in this business you could
choose to do the right or the wrong
thing
and so often people too that's why you
can get away with the wrong thing for so
long so many people support you doing
the wrong
thing that's why i respect the new
younger ceo of vicom
because he had a situation with dave had
a situation with nick cannon hopefully
they could write that situation
but it's like you can turn back the
hands of time you can say you know what
that was fucked up you know what i'm
saying
i'm older now and now that i look back
you know i and you can do it too because
you can't afford to because a
motherfucker has made so much money for
so many motherfucking people and given
so many jobs
yep and at what point do we stop saying
i should be so lucky
to get fucked over by you that's how we
treated it for the longest time yep
and that's the whole thing about when i
say to a certain extent
hollywood was alive for so long we also
didn't know what we were worth that's
the other thing is that
is that the amount of money they were
paying us really this is so much money
because we
a lot of us don't come from money a lot
of us don't know we don't have we don't
have the confidence
to be able to challenge you you like i'm
gonna get it that's what happens so much
with people in music and everything's
like the first thing your first hit is
like
i made it but what he's taught people
and a lot of people talk
the toughest thing is to know your value
and want the respect
because they're going to try to devalue
all the time but the thing is
this is the beauty of social media
whatever you know your value
you instantly know your value that's
interesting you know your value
what is your value well i know this
cable show that you produce
it's only 150 000 people watching this a
day
i know it's 10 million people of my
followers
that i can drop your ad in everything
any fucking time i want
do you want to play this game yeah which
one and by the way mine are a captive
audience
they're not watching by accident on the
tv that's just on in the lobby
they're signing in they're a captive
audience they trust me and they want to
connect to me and some of them are still
trolls and assholes
but for the most part you have something
this business is all about
showing something to somebody so they
can sell ads and make money
right right but now that's the beauty of
it is now that
we you you can you feel your power you
feel your power instantly and then but
then we didn't know because
it used to be okay you do a tv show
let's say you make 50 000 an episode
that's so much money
but then of course you're giving away 25
percent and then half to the
government's you're coming home with
like 20 000
25 000 uh dollars for a show that's
still a fucking huge deal to someone
that grew up without money
i should be so lucky and then you're
doing press for free none of us were
asking questions about like you do press
for anything that people never
understand this supply so what we doing
applies to like uh
professional sports and everything you
see somebody get a huge contract
40 million a year fuck that all he do is
throwing football
yeah you're looking at that for a
company to be able
to for for organization to be able to
pay you 40 million a year
have you ever asked yourself how much
fucking money they're making
so then you're making let's say 25 000 a
year on that sitcom and then the
advertiser's bounty and whatever
um uh fucking trader joe's quit legal
zoom whatever
whatever the fuck evian they're paying
and then we get you get that 25 percent
because all that tons of money is going
to the lawyers the pr people
you're paying so many people's bills
this is nothing you don't no it goes
directly to us i don't know what you
call it you got the lawyers you got the
agents
you got uncle sam and then you got the
posse
oh yeah the proxy the posse yeah yeah
yeah
the the yeah the the this is what people
understand about that
when you grew up with nothing or you
never was able to
and it's so easy to get caught up in
that it's like okay i can afford it
and you know it's not like you floss
anything but you want to be able to say
yeah hey guys
all going to have a good time hey we're
going to have a good time but the
problem is
is most of us get famous before we get
rich and they don't know that
oh no no no no listen let me tell you
something
if you're on tv
[Applause]
that was a different thing that is so
fucking true man it's like oh i see you
like oh
oh shit you got a hundred thousand likes
on that post there you go no no no you
don't get a
dollar for every like i don't know how
you think this business works
yeah but that's how it is but that's
that's the um that's where people
misunderstand
like what we do but like you said the
dopest thing
is when you know what your value is then
you can negotiate in different places
and if you can have the patience just to
wait that's a hard thing to do
especially
coming from nothing but as we go on
people are starting to get more
comfortable and more confident with that
and networks and stuff i know they i
know they um
i know i know they're a little nervous
mm-hmm oh they're for
sure because it's like this another
thing that we don't need you anymore
you're not the only game in town anymore
we don't have to suck your dick
like literally especially to work in a
situation
like like i said you and i right you're
like
when we first start we we want to be
good some people some people just want
the fame
but once you get past that oh you want
to take a picture hey everybody whatever
because that fuse you for a while then
once you get past that shit he was like
this you know what
i've done everything i'm going to do
with fame i've fucked all the chicks i
want to do with fame
i've got them to pop the ropes i've got
to pop up
now and this especially so when you get
oh do you like this i don't need all
that shit
just a simple shit yeah that's one of
the things that made me want to be a
a river ninja but also let me you
realize that
the the richest actresses in the world
they're already at like 40 building
their lotion empire their branding
empire reese witherspoon has this giant
clothing ever
uh uh uh i thought goddamn chuck norris
infomercial the other night yes you got
to be the gwyneth paltrow
of fucking like what i did out of
candles i did that with candles not at
why can't you have 50 fucking lotions
and candles and shit like she's so
and that they all have a backup plan
even though they're the most famous
people in the world
are working on a backup plan because
they know that they're but another thing
they do too they get it
like some people get addicted to the
whole process of starting something from
scratch and watching it build
yeah you know what i mean like damon
john he's one of those people
damon john has a great story started he
came up with this company fubu
oh he called us by us he started like
five t-shirts but what he would do
is like get him in music videos and
stuff and i was telling a story the
other day how many times are you like
you're looking at success now
but you don't nobody ever want to
acknowledge the level of rejection in
the nose
i give joe rogan as an example everybody
when they see a podcast i'll be joe
rogan but nobody want to be joe rogan
15 years ago no nobody would want to be
with nobody when he was on fear factor
eating bugs
yeah they didn't do that but they only
thing what people connect with
is the finished product and they ignore
the entire process
and for what we do if you think about it
we have the most
in the process yes you know what i'm
saying like when you get when you say
okay i'm gonna do this i'm gonna do this
and when you get there everybody's like
i can't believe you're dead you're like
i'm on to the next project yep yeah
because we get off on on the process
right right i can't believe like my way
of thought and
my thought my way of thinking and me
wanting to be an entrepreneur came from
fucking kayaking
yeah well because you get clarity i
think it's like when you're in the city
too long especially
a place like la it's just like you get
hypnotized you forget the
the the choices you have like i moved
out here to the woods and it's like you
just sit out look at the mountain every
day and you're just like i have more
choices than i thought and you're not
waking up and just on autopilot like
instagram twitter you're like let me sit
back remember when i used to have
ideas and visions and not on my phone
and remember when i like
you know that's the only time you can
come up with something original and
really sort of find out what your where
your
heart wants to go when you edit when
you're at a calm relaxing stressless
because when i'm on instagram i'm just
competing with other comedians i'm like
they're doing clubs they're doing a
special i need to go special and i'm
my career trajectory is just based on me
being competitive or
insecure of what i'm seeing on instagram
saying what the fuck do i actually want
to do when i'm not
in compare and despair and when i'm not
like they have a special i need to do a
special gym seeing
i was making so many decisions out of
fear right and then when you go out in
the woods or you know
spend some time with yourself which so
few you do build a different level of
confidence
yeah and you can look back on your
career just be like i've done that i
don't need to do that what about this
like this is
so um this lotion i feel like this is
going to be
i feel like you're going to have more
money than chappelle soon and that's
going to make your relationships
this motherfucker making 20 30 million a
pop
and it's all good i gotta say uh
deserves it all
i don't know what i talk about i was
just support we do have to talk about
the vaccine in a second
you brassed about that the black vaccine
the black the black scene
flaxseed i noticed i think pfizer and my
derma
okay pfizer modern johnson johnson those
are the white vaccines
okay the johnson johnson i think that's
specific
for the african-american because it's
one shot it's one they know they can't
get them back for two yeah they know
we're scared of needles it's like fuck
that they're gonna be late for the
second we're gonna be late for the
second shot
it's that one shot one shot one kill
it's like the marines
uh a phrase for for snipers one shot
one kill that's all we're doing but i'm
going to get it
because i it's so funny because you and
i had similar experiences with
contracting covet yeah and i talked
about you know i heard
my doctor thinks i got it through my
eyeballs really mm-hmm
this funny thing you say that yeah your
doctor nobody knows how the fuck that's
what no one knows fucking
anything you know you could i know it
wasn't an orgy i had
why how how do you know
i mean corona can't can't live when
there's more than three people having
sex that's what the streets tell me
that's what street saying but it's so
funny tears kill it yeah tears kill it
yeah but you didn't for you because if
you have any eyeballs well maybe the
tears are straight yeah maybe i yeah
drain it in my mouth and the droplets
also i was uh uh yeah i got it through
whatever however if i got it but i had
over like three weeks and then could not
remember my home address for like four
weeks see i don't know what level you
had like i think it's
levels and like when when you talk about
it people just want to put it into one
category
like it's so much fear around it which
it should be yeah
not downplaying any of that but what
people don't understand is like
everybody is case by case yep and i
talked about this on my podcast
subscribe to the donnie rollins show on
youtube and uh all's
plot pad podcast podcast platforms
do it right now hit the button bitch why
wildest podcast out there
most entertaining uh and the best
opening song
of any podcast i've ever shout out to
rizzo for that but it was interesting
because
um for me the experience
wasn't as bad as i thought it was going
to be and it was kind of like i couldn't
really
share that because people like oh it
could have been worse like we were
talking on the phone before i came
the worst thing about kova is the covet
shaming that comes with it
people make you feel so fucked up that
you're not dying
they're like wait a minute they want you
to be in more pain than you're in they
want because they want to be able to say
see told you yep see look at you out
here trying to live your
life look at that look at that look at
you out here trying to test people make
sure
uh things are okay oh then when you test
people like in the case we did oh you
guys are so privileged whatever
only thing we were trying to do was give
some type of normal life only thing
we're trying to do is like
open up a like in a case with yellow
springs you know what i'm saying yeah
the whole town economy popped up
hotels being used but more than that
people had a mental release
they had something to do and no matter
what people say something to look
forward to but it also set an example to
us like
putting that on social media like made
me go oh shit i can do
let's do this responsibly safely there's
a whole generation of comedians
that before the pandemic we're just
about to get their tonight show spot
we're just about to get their netflix
thing we're just about
and then had to be on the bench for two
i mean that's a long time to be off the
fucking bench that's a long time to not
have income maybe not you and me
but i was like if i was a comedian and i
was just about to
you know make it i had just gotten my a
grade set together to
you know and then everything is gone all
your dates are off the schedule it just
like drove me nuts that no one could
even get social media content
for their socials i mean there was going
to be a whole a a bunch of comedians
that when we came back
they've moved home and they work at tgi
fridays i mean this half this business
isn't going to be here when we get back
imagine the people that said they wanted
to start doing comment when this
happened
there's nowhere there's they're on only
fans yeah
when my situation recovery it was so
funny because you know i kind of like
wasn't really
talk to people because i just got sick
of people like
uh not understanding you know but like i
would
this one guy called me one of my friends
he called me said so how you doing i
said
he said how you feeling i said i feel
great and he was like oh man
i hope you feel better
i'm like what is better what kind of
grade you want to tony the tiger grace
i feel amazing to be worse than it is
you know what i mean you're like i'm
doing okay and they're like all right
well
it's gonna get worse like you're gonna
it's like why do you want me to be there
and everything
like i heard people like what what what
symptoms you have
i don't have any symptoms you don't have
any symptoms you don't they they wish
you want bad news people
want bad news and then also people
they'll shame you they'll be like you
gotta test you gotta test
and then you go oh we tested and they go
well those tests aren't accurate well
what is it
it's worth it always it's always it's
always gonna
be something different and like in our
situation like
see we told you guys now you guys could
be out there spreading it
man when it should happen with our crew
it felt like a military
operation like like when you when you
create a bubble
i don't give as nba uh uh major league
baseball
when you create a bubble you know any
day
it could be popped yeah nothing is 100
guaranteed but here's and we don't know
enough about this fucking thing to know
if you're popping it but here's the most
important part
and in our case with us it's like what
happens when the bubble is burst
like in our case when everybody was he
was panicked whatever and i remember
dave tell him he said donna this is the
reason why we test
yep we test so we have the knowledge we
know when we to make personal choices
whatever and in our case
it was like when when when our boat got
busted
um it was instant quarantine
yep it was everybody even people that
were there
married couples people there were
couples that were together
separated well it's separated and in the
thing that i was like
they were relieved thank god that was
relieved from my fucking heart another
thing like
in the case with us the thing that you
know i felt
comfortable with like the sense of
teamwork yeah you know i mean like
we we when it happened you know you
worry about food and stuff like that you
worry about your life
but like when it happened for us like
when i found out that i was
positive 30 minutes later in front of my
daughter
was every vitamin known to man it was a
thermometer
you know all the finger thing the the
the
pulse oximeter oregano oil like shit
like
i had a pharmacy right and fucking
thermometer no joe rogan mushroom
vitamins
charcoal kettle bells yeah like
everything right and that was just like
this
you felt like you felt like now because
you felt you felt like
the way the teamwork kicked in you felt
like oh
we're going to do everything to get
through this together yep even with food
situations like okay
now lunch will be delivered 1 30 every
day that's right dinner
7 o'clock if you need anything from
walmart or whatever now people are like
yeah you had the money to do it no i
didn't
he did i'm sorry you weren't marshalls
that was you could afford marshalls from
your
your creams yeah but of course you get a
couple of you guys
you got marshall's money everybody it
all kicked it all kicked in to the point
where
like you had to test out like people
that were
like people that were negative became
runners
ah yeah yeah yeah yeah you became
yeah right and like we have we you have
a runner
you have the runners and then when when
you uh when you test out because
the test out you have to have three
negative pcrs in a row in a row which
the pcrs take two days to go those are
the real tests no no
they got shorter than that okay so he
had the rush runs yeah he did get money
from companies damn that check
came too quick yeah it was expensive but
you had that but like
when you think like okay you got a group
of people that are being quarantined
yeah you would think when they finally
test out and free and okay you think
they were like i gotta get out of here
that wasn't the case
it was like like you wanted to like hey
guys
i'm negative now but what can i do to
help yep that's how i was yeah we even
had a we even had uh we call it
a yard day right yard day when we get 30
30 minutes of fresh air we didn't go
around
the the hotel we had to go back at a
hotel
uh down 12 flights of steps and the way
you did it like if you wanted to go
on yard time you had to raise your hand
in the chat like i want to go yard time
and then
they would bring your fresh n95 mask and
gloves
right like two mask gloves and then you
had a warden
that would go with you yeah the warden
was just somebody guess how he got his
his job
just by being negative just michelle
wolf in a bee
yeah costume michelle wolf yeah but you
see the fucking housemates
when you do um when you do your yard
time you had a warden right
and like some people just were very
abusive of their powers
like on one of the textbooks like this
okay your maggots
right all right get in line man it's
like stanford prison experiment
everybody starts becoming a fucking
monster
everybody's an asshole we had a wonder i
called him little hitler
gave him too much power yeah too much so
you know what's literally see this is
what's happening is people are feeling
uh because of what's going on with kovid
they're feeling the sense of power
everyone wants to be the hall monitor
everyone you walk you go to the grocery
store
where's your mask and you're like this
is the this is the first time you got to
do that you get to yell at me
yes i became that person oh shit i meant
to tell you you didn't let me finish my
story right
so with your time with me i went on a
couple right whitney i don't know
i i became that asshole i was napoleon
on steroids right
you know so but it was so funny because
napoleon wants to say
the day did i test it out i couldn't
wait
to be warned for a day
he was like all right everybody well
today your time will be supervised by
donnell
right anybody that wants your time
raise your hand now right and then i
just was i didn't
i wanted to violate everybody i was like
i was like yeah
and we're meeting up at 1500 hours
i know the average motherfucker don't
know what that type of military
experience is i feel like they're going
to be late and they can't go to yard
time
right so hey say hi to maggie maggie
listen
so um so and i was like this i thought
it was so fucked up like
it was like 80 degrees outside yeah i
know people trying to be in the hotel
room
and then i was like anybody want your
time nobody
went to yard time that day they was like
fucked i'd rather
be cooped up in this goddamn hotel and
to do that shit
um uh so wait you have not gotten the
vaccine you're
out you you so you have 90 days you got
the antibodies now yeah and you're just
so funny because i told my
i'm starting to get different gigs and
stuff yeah and but i told you you're
booking a rogue yeah yeah but i told
because i'm kind of confident
not comfortable with the things i'm
doing that i'm getting good time with my
son yeah
and then it's kind of different because
although places are opening up the money
is different
now because we only limited capacity
we're at half capacity and
it's it's it's uh texas is a full
capacity now inside but yeah and also
not only that
clubs have not made any money for the
past year so we're trying to come back
we're also kind of going all right i
told my folks i was like
you know what i'm just going to chill
until like may but then once i got the
covert i was like i got 90 days of
antibodies i called my age i was like
yeah that's one of those one-nighters
let's go i'm flying i'll go to the
stress factory people are shoulder to
fucking shoulder yeah i'll do any venue
yeah but it's like and but then when you
do that people like see you're still out
there playing games with it i'm like
nothing is going to make anybody happy
and this is going to come to a point we
talked about it before is personal
responsibility
what do you want to do what chances are
you going to take that don't involve
anybody else
yeah and we're going to take risks and
if you and if you and you know i just
did salt lake city at half capacity and
it was
wise yes it was great people half the
people had little cards saying they were
vaccinated people were so careful and
respectful of each other
and it was um it was it was after like a
couple minutes it just felt normal you
know there was a second i felt like i
was bombing and i was like because
there's this thing when you see empty
seats where you're just like wait a
second
you know there was like a couple stuff
like that but it was fucking awesome and
like there were a bunch of people that
were like hey i can't come i live with
my grandma and i'm like great i'll be
back in a year dude i'm
coming every city i'm doing in half
capacity now i'm gonna come back to but
like we
these places are gonna go out of
business if we don't start going i did a
show
hollywood improv just pretty much like
was my home club when i first got here
the first
people that would let me go any time i
wanted and they were trying they've been
trying to think about you got businesses
that keep trying yeah
you know like what can we do what can we
do not that we're trying to go crazy but
what can we do
adapt yeah so uh they told me they were
doing it the patio
was open yep right and i and i was like
oh i'll host because they've been like
hosting my podcast so
i feel like whatever they want me for
and i would i just did a podcast there
it's a live one uh no not live just me i
just
i use the uh the the room with the bar
oh nice
main room so um and i just did a podcast
and i was like okay they're trying
something different
and i was like do they even have an
audience over there who's over there
and then uh ricardo said bud i'm like
friedman look i was like bud who
right and he said freeman and i went
from like not really tripping so like oh
my god but freeman's gonna be there
the only the founder of the impression
like the number one guy
you know what i'm saying is like and i
don't give a guy that used to decide
if you had a career or not back in the
day and i'm telling you if you
are in the game of comedy and don't
think of him as royalty and i was like
oh my god what am i going to say what am
i going to say
and he's like seeing him he was in a
wheelchair wow
right seeing him and uh the
crazy thing was the last show i did
before the pandemic
popped off was at the improv i'm still
on
on a set list and then for me because
bud is like he's very old yeah and
there's no hating shit
like he's at the age like someone should
do a documentary i hope someone's going
to document her
he's at that age now where the last time
you see him
you think it could possibly be the last
time you see him
and he took it right now it's the last
time we could see anyone frankly that's
true
that's true but it was just so dope for
him
and i talked about i was like this is a
brand that's been around forever and
they're trying
you know what i'm saying yeah we just
did um irvine improv outside and cars
i love that one you know that this
friday uh uh movie theaters are opening
in los angeles this weekend movie
theaters full capacity movie theaters
and indoor dining is open this weekend i
know
we're going to see how we navigate
through it i will say from the beginning
we were more educated
we know simple things we can do could uh
cut down on the cases wash your hands
yeah masking out but just hold people
everybody thinks like it's the worst
thing to open stuff up
but i don't think it's a bad idea
because now we're educated people didn't
know how you could get or anything so
we're taking the precautions yeah
and also um yeah the facts they say that
in uh what is it in california the
vaccine that's going to be available to
everyone in
april and the whole country may 1st may
1st in the whole country
adults will be eligible all adults will
be eligible may 1st for the vaccine and
then the the thing is the vaccines have
become so politicized that's going to be
the next problem
yeah you know what i mean is like taking
the vaccine or not and i know that
people are really split on it and
there's a lot of trauma in the back
black community around vaccinations
it's not vaccination we don't like shots
needles what
needles get away let's give us a feel
google tuskegee
and you'll get why some of your black
friends are a little trepidatious
about the fucking vaccine i understand
you know what i mean and uh uh
j marion sims i just like to bring up as
well who is you know
infamously a a doctor who experimented
on black women there was a statue of him
up in central park
i believe up until about a year ago so
there is a lot of trauma around vaccines
and so
uh you know but even with that said
you're like
what the fuck are you gonna do like even
what happened with us it felt like a
chicken pox party yeah
you know what i felt like yeah everybody
come through but i was like i told dave
i said yo we put the herd in the
community i say we put the hurt and
immunity you heard
and his fucking punk ass in the darkest
times we always have a joke
when he got it he was like oh man i
thought it was gonna be you first
thanks but we got through it yeah we
didn't it wasn't a joke
we found some humor in certain
situations but we got through it we were
lucky that everybody in our crew that
had it
everybody tested out and didn't even
have it back like like what was the um
like diversity of symptoms that's the
worst the the worst
symptom one uh or one of our guys he was
a younger guy
we thought he was borderline and getting
pneumonia you know what i mean but
he pulled through yeah you know what i'm
saying it's like
it's just it affects everybody so
differently and i think for me and also
it gets psychological like
like um grace and emily thought like i
was really losing my memory i was but i
was also like dehydrated i couldn't keep
food down and eating and then i
i was uh i went off my antidepressants
uh like cold turkey because i couldn't
keep anything down so i was like i don't
know how much of this is the coved
how much of this is a cold turkey how
much of it is the psychological shit
because i was like i can't remember shit
and then i was like wait i could never
remember where my keys were that's not
cool but that's just how i've always
been
then you being denied i wasn't i was in
loss of smell
taste denial because i had this i got
these jelly beans here to make sure
let me tell you what i did i'll tell you
i'll tell you what i did let me tell you
what i did i was doing my own little
shit in my room
like i was like uh i would everybody say
you gotta say i was like i don't gotta
say
no loss of smell i was like i could
still smell and i had one of those
essential um diffusers or whatever they
send out the lavender
oils and i had when i was like i could
smell but i realized that i had that
shit damn near all the way in my nose
i used to smell from across the room i
had that shit in my nose
and i was giving myself a taste this is
a crazy shit i would turn the lights off
of my room right
and dump a bowl of jell-o uh uh uh gummy
bears
and i would taste them no lights were
just to see if
you knew what they knew what flavor
[Laughter]
let me do my fucking joke all right
fucking hating ass
coffee giving ass motherfucker i'll take
everything back give me my motherfucker
so these jelly beans hold on hold on
these jelly beans are this is a jelly
bean roulette so wait
you know jelly belly jelly beans you
know you so these i do know that i've
never what i do know the jelly bean can
someone get me the box quick what i do
we must have one in there
so jelly beans are the most racist candy
you can have
cause you point out a black one pull out
a black one uh
show me a black one why are you digging
so long no but there's where
maybe i ate them all because we love
them so much nah i want to see the
goddamn give me the big bag
they're uh liquid licorice is the black
one and guess what's so rich about that
it's that close to nicorish
licorice licorice come on man it feels
like you're stressed but
nigger is feels feels like a stretch but
i have just enough white guilt to let
you have it
you can have it but here's like these
are jelly bellies and half of them taste
like the
normal delicious flavor like oh you
about to give me that hospital the
other half the other ones are like are
like uh
bad like dog shit and like so you
i don't be a part of this see how white
people think shit is so much fun
hey danielle you want to take a chance
while eating this shit so like look
let's both eat which one do you want
what color do you want do you want to do
try coconut butter popcorn peach juicy
pear tutti fruity
uh chopped fruity okay so tutti frutti
this is either rooted
it's gonna either be tutti frutti or
stinky socks
one of us wait which one's tutti frutti
the oh the
this one okay that okay so that's either
tutti frutti or stinky socks
you know you bet don't spit it out you
better swallow
don't spit it out don't spit it out
but smell this yeah i know like smell
that it smell like how did you get
that smell
[Applause]
yo that shit really smells like a fucked
up ass
sock oh my god
yo i don't want to play anymore okay
well yeah
yeah stop while you're ahead that's
going to be it for me
oh my god how did you like the way the
coffee smelled you got to try it
how did you like it yeah no it smells
fucking delicious but i need a grinder
can you you know what else you can do is
the coffee pods i am i'm on it the
carrot pods
yeah so good and then even like instant
coffee
i'm on it nice what else like what other
products i just that's it i just had the
the coffee i am going to partner up with
um i'm
in a process of partnering with thc
designed to come up with my own um
weed strand nice i don't know if you
follow my instagram but i started saying
in the morning because i'm always up
early
your ig lives yeah i always say who's up
we up who sleep they sleep
so what they're like 6 a.m uh uh uh
pacific time
yeah because what i know it's tough for
uh
on on a pst time but i kind of do that
because
i got a lot of followers on the east
coast and i do it around seven so
it's early here the morning has started
on the east coast but most people wake
up around that time we're comics like
most people are up but
what i want to do is like you know i
just want to encourage people to
get inspired be motivated and get up and
do something and you know you do
something crazy because recently i did
my version of a polar plunge right i was
in san diego
and i dove into the ocean it was
inspired by white chicken it was there
the day before
she walked past me dethroved and just
fucking dove in the ocean
and then the next day i did it and then
as any time you do something like crazy
people
i want to know what the fuck he was
smoking right so i'm gonna have a strand
that inspires you to smoke what i smoke
and do some adventurous stuff
so so when you how stone were you when
you jumped into it i wasn't
oh and i'm gonna tell you it made me
feel so good good reason why
your instagram i hate you look the
reason i hate you so much
your instagram is so wrong it's so wrong
and the reason why it was a reason why
my
life every year on the news you hear see
these people do the polar bear
polar bear challenge it's always white
folks right and i always say they're
crazy
but when i saw that chick do it i was
like what do you get out of it
and then i was on live when i saw her do
it so my followers like you should do it
you should do it
so the next day i did it and when i came
with it when i came out of that ocean
i felt like a new person like my body
was tingling for three days straight
but the thing that was exciting for me
is that my followers it inspired them to
want to challenge their fears
and do something different had nothing
to do with that white chick was bad as a
motherfucker yeah
do you should do a show called just like
donnell does white shit
you know what that's a good idea i know
i'll do something with you yeah i would
love that
we can just go and like do what we talk
let's do like i want to do
a travel show some fun shit yeah what
like what i mean
there's a i think what's what is
becoming very clear to me
is like i love you and annie's
relationship too
annie lerman my fight i'm obsessed i
love her yeah
love her and i think that for me for the
longest time i believe comedians were
kind of
conditioned to compete with each other
because there was only so many pieces of
the pie
and now she's found her own lane and now
we're all supporting each other and the
more we help each other actually the
more successful we
like all the ships rise with the water
and we're not
especially female comics i don't know
how what it's like with black comics or
it's just
i feel like we were it was like me
versus you for the because there was
only one spot for a woman on the line up
for the longest time right well that's
how it was in hollywood people thought
was only one black comet could it be
popping at the same time that's right
like you say everybody's got their lane
feel like this i feel like this pandemic
and podcasts have given comedians a
chance to be like no we're all in the
same
fucking team dude it's hard for people
to understand that but
these networks want us to go you get a
sitcom and you don't and then that puts
us against each other you know
watch what's going to be the chain watch
what uh joe rogan does in austin
watch what dave chappelle does in yellow
springs can't wait for his people people
are making pivots i know um
you you're talking about that on that uh
drive-in show you know i just want to
say i meant to sit on top of the show
but
i uh i did uh i used for years i did the
dc improv thanksgiving weekend that one
of my favorite clubs in the world
ten years i did it and then last year we
were doing a club but we did it at uh
rfk stadium
parking lot and it was i did two shows
uh 280 cars at each show that's the
sellout for that
and then they just approached me the
other day i want to do i'm going to go
back
again april 9th through the 10th it's
another driving show the weather's going
to be better
and then i'm bringing is this on your
website no it's just um i haven't done
this the first announcement i made of it
or nice but it's going to be uh
april 10th april 9th and the 10th rfk
stadium and
jesus but it's not it's just a part it's
a parking lot wow
but it's a good year in cars and it's in
cars so in cars it's actually pretty
cool because
the audio goes into the car radio
station yeah so it's like you had a
movie theater it's like
yeah exactly and you can hear it and
there's huge screens and i actually
think it's a better way to watch comedy
with on those huge screens
and that's why like you go to some
people they encourage you to beep your
horn to show that you
i don't think you need i don't like that
when you come out they do and then
you're done
you don't and you're done because you
got to realize that it take a special
community understand that you got to get
in your own zone
you're not going to get the sound of
laughter like that
but you got to realize their captive
audience like you say this
your fm player is playing it and you
look at it like you're the drivetrain
and give us a second to find our pacing
you know i mean that's the thing about
it is because the first time i did the
driving i was like this is weird there's
a weird delay i'm not
feeling the contagious energy i work you
know and then i was like
we've done so many fucking crazy shows
whether it's bowling alleys or
strip clubs or whatever like we can
adapt to these
crazy the good ones can we yeah exactly
the good ones can we just give
us a second you know that's it but it's
good and it's giving us opportunities
but i say
uh in about 11. are you moving often am
i losing you too
no i'm not going to move to austin okay
but we'll be there a lot i'm super super
super super connected to yellow springs
ohio mm-hmm
because uh like my son really enjoyed it
you know what did you consider moving
there i i wouldn't because
his mom is so connected mm-hmm to this
and you know
it's just a tough one but i think like i
was like i i was wondering how dave
chappelle got to yellow springs
and him and he went to africa first no
no
but his mother and father i think they
separated at a young age
and his dad took on a teaching job in
yellow spring so i was like
so he would spend summers with his dad
in yellow spring so
that's something that i would look
forward to because you know the
community that's there my son loves
nature you know i mean i don't need to
get any new friends and shit like
everything that i need to
support his happiness and my happiness
is this so
and also half the half of our shows are
on the east coast like it is good to
have to
to operate from uh like i'm thinking
about getting a place in like virginia
or something kind of where i'm uh
from from maybe back in dc so that i
have us even if it's like an apartment
to be able to do our east coast shows
and it not be
a full day of travel all the way back to
l.a look but the thing about it
this what the pandemic has done it made
us think outside the box that's right
it you you feel empowered
and then you're making like calculated
decisions on what your next move is
going to be yeah
and then another thing is like
motherfuckers saying russian to be
hollywood hollywood hollywood no
and then last question are you on
clubhouse i uh
yeah i am but it's tough for me because
it it's just like
we making everybody a moderator yep
everybody thinks that an authority
and i'm so you know me i'm loud i come
in loud
blow a room up and then i leave quietly
like i'm like okay leave finally yeah
yeah i'm like leave it quietly
i'm gonna leave quietly i'm just
interested uh if a lot of comics are
doing shows on there and what that looks
like and it seems like some comics are
making money and
and getting opportunities and there's a
lot of access and you know we're about
to open like not open up but
we're gonna things are about to i know
people it's not over we know it's not
but things are gonna get a lot better i
love you man
i love you thank you for uh where you
going monday you're leaving i'm going
back to austin we're getting ready to
start doing shows yeah
we're doing five shows in austin and
stubbs shout out to all the people at
stubs
and then we're gonna do that three um
shows in in houston at the um
house of blues nice yup so it's going to
be so full capacity now in texas
no but inside i think but we're still
not going to take those chances
and dave is the only person that takes
tests everybody in the ordinance
it's easy it is to be like we can be
wide open we still don't feel
comfortable there so nice that's what
we're gonna continue to do the things
that
we do tomorrow so people come early and
they have to test kind of before they
come in yeah but the system is so
sharp man they turn a lot of people
around really really quickly wow again
the testing is no cure any of that it's
only by the way he should start a
testing
who's going to start the company the
quick testing company he should start it
for venues and theaters and clubs a
thing that you walk through a fucking
tsa whatever looking thing and you're
tested like there's a lot of people on
our team that um
are venturing into that business good
good flow
because you guys are figuring out how to
do it quickly and fast like
own it we don't know the only thing we
can do is to try that's the only thing
we can do yeah
i love you um thank you for giving me
maggie thank you for giving me that
coffee it was delicious
um i love you donnell rawlings.org
danielrollins.com yo i'm not i don't
live with org lifestyle
organization oh org is for
saveabitch.com
uh you got to get this lotion you guys i
have you know that i'm the queen of
a shiny face i am the queen of moisture
and this is truly
the fucking oiliest uh
body butter i've ever had i mean i'm
literally feel my hair what is my moist
is rising feel my hair i mean it's like
we could look
we couldn't hold on to each other
stop it girl oh shit don't know
rolex i love you thank you for coming
baby
[Music]
four four four
[Applause]
you